In Sidney Prescott’s room, next to her desk,
there is a poster for Swamp Ophelia, an album
by The Indigo Girls, a folk-rock band from the 1980s.
As you can see on this poster,
the band is a 2-piece. The latest single from
that album at the time Scream came out was
also called “The Power of Two.”
This is symbolic because of the twist in Scream:
the fact that there are two killers.
The power of two is the reason that they were able to
trick police and clear Billy’s name as a suspect.
With this in mind, we can go back
and find many more clues about Scream’s
double trouble antagonists. To learn the connection
between Stu Macher’s room and the video
rental store, stick around to the end of this
video.
♪ Metal Music ♪
Everybody knows that Scream is a satire, a
horror movie that makes a commentary about
horror movies. But I think a lot of people
overlook what a satire actually is. So let’s
take it back to the basic definition.
Satire is the use of humor, irony, exaggeration,
or ridicule to expose and criticize something.
By that definition, satire has always been
around, long before Scream and long before movies.
Even the slasher genre had already
come out with films like Student Bodies or
Evil Dead 2. So let's just drop the charade
that Scream is some kind of first of it's
kind movie.
What one of the things that makes Scream loved
by many is its ability to satirize without
turning to comedy, which led to it being a
legitimate force in the genre that it was
aiming to expose. In fact, Scream was so successful,
and so many tried to imitate it, that it’s
acute self-awareness became the norm for a
while.
Audiences had seen this happen in television
a few years earlier with The Simpsons, the
family sitcom which attacked the positive
family values of other sitcoms on the air
at the time.
– [Lisa] Wow, it must be expensive to produce
all these cartoons.
– [Producer] Well, we cut corners. Sometimes
to save money, our animators will reuse the
same backgrounds over and over and over again.
As a result, everybody wanted to make
a show with that cutting edge social commentary
like The Simpsons. But the Simpsons was a
comedy; a comedy that made fun of the TV families
of 80s, then surpassed them and became the
TV family of the 90s. Scream was able to follow
this blueprint, but for horror movies. You
can make the argument that Scream is funny,
but it’s a different kind of funny; it’s
pretty clear the intention is not to have
you – as they put it in the 90s – ROFL.
That isn’t to say screenwriter Kevin Williamson
and director Wes Craven don’t understand
the formula of setup and punchline. They actually
transform that concept and use it for some
of the scares in the movie instead of laughs.
For example, there are a number of scenes
that end with a big push-in to a spot in the
background, where Ghostface can then be seen
lurking. We see this outside of Sid’s house,
and at the grocery store, so we start to associate
that particular camera movement with the appearance
of our antagonist. When Tatum is getting beers
from the garage, we see the camera brush past
her and focus on the doorframe. It starts
to elevate our heart rates, but then, nothing
happens. That’s such a clever way to build
suspense. Then we see the door close, but
it’s just the cat, so we’re no longer
on edge, making it all the more effective
when Ghostface does appear in front of the
closed door.
There are other techniques like this used
to throw off the audience, and of course some
clever easter eggs from Wes Craven, so let’s
get into the Things You Missed.
(SLICE)
Even the title, Scream, feels like it’s
poking fun at some of the so-simple-it-could-be-about-anything
titles of Alfred Hitchcock’s horror movies,
like Blackmail! Murder! Sabotage! Rope! And
of course, Psycho! The beginning of Scream
pulls out a trick that was used in Psycho.
Psycho came out in 1960 and it’s biggest
star was it’s female lead Janet Leigh, who
played Marion Crane. She is prominently featured
on the poster, so audiences were totally shocked
when they killed her off very early on in
the movie.
Scream’s biggest star is Drew Barrymore,
who is similarly the face of the marketing
campaign, so many people were shocked to see
her brutally disemboweled in the opening scene.
There’s kind of a lineage that exists connecting
the most prominent slasher movie of each generation.
When I covered Halloween here on Things You
Missed, I spent a lot of time talking about
how it was inspired by Psycho. Now the torch
is being passed down again to Scream. We can
see this in the name: Loomis. Psycho had Samuel
Loomis, Halloween had Dr. Sam Loomis, and
Scream had Billy Loomis, who, after revealing
he is one of the killers, drops a quote from
Psycho.
–[Billy] We all go a little mad sometimes.
– Billy is also most likely the one on the
phone who asks Casey to guess
his favorite horror movie.
– [Casey] A Nightmare on Elm Street!
– [Caller] I like that movie, it was scary.
– [Casey] Well the first one was, but the
rest sucked.
I was about to get up here and say that this
was a joke by director Wes Craven, who also
directed the first Nightmare on Elm Street,
but not the five sequels that would follow.
But apparently it was in the script before
it was ever decided that Craven would be the
director.
– [Craven] I kinda wanted to take that out,
I did not write that line.
That answers my other question about that
line. Wes returned to the franchise to direct
Wes Craven’s New Nightmare, in case you
didn’t know who the director of Wes Craven’s
New Nightmare was… it was Wes Craven, which
was the most recent Freddy Krueger movie at
the time Scream was made. It just seemed strange
that he would diss himself like that. Apparently
the line later on, where Tatum mixes him up
with Halloween director John Carpenter…
–[Tatum] Don't go there, Sid. You’re starting
to sound like some Wes Carpenter flick or
something.
…was also in the script before
Craven’s involvement, but it kind of works
better now, seeing as how Scream uses Halloween
as a template for the horror movie tropes
that it satirizes.
After a few aggressive anonymous calls, Casey
immediately picks up the phone and yells…
–[Casey] Listen ***hole!
What if that had been someone else calling
just then? That would have been very rude
Casey!
After breaking into the house, we see Ghostface
looking around for her. My question is:
why doesn’t he just try calling the phone again
and going towards the sound of the ringtone?
It seems logical that she would keep the phone
on her to try to get help, so she might have
forgotten to silence it.
After Ghostface catches up with her, there
are a couple of easter eggs that play out
on the Beckers’ side lawn.
(THUNDER)
♪ Industrial Music ♪
As I mentioned, Halloween is the main template
that Scream uses for it’s satire. It’s
the movie that Casey is planning to watch
in the opening, and it’s the movie that
crushes Stu’s head in the finale. There’s
another Halloween connection after Casey manages
to get outside and sees her parents going
back to the house. Despite the title of this
movie, she is unable to find her scream and
get her parents attention.
–[Casey] (barely audible) Mom…
In Halloween II, we see this same phenomenon
take place as Laurie Strode tries to yell
for help outside of Haddonfield Hospital.
–[Laurie] (barely audible) Help… help...
Then there’s yet another Halloween reference
just moments later.
–[Mr. Becker] Get in the car. Drive down to the MacKenzies’.
Call the police.
– When Laurie and the kids are targeted
by Michael Myers, she gives them a similar
order.
–[Laurie] I want you to go down the street to the
MacKenzies' house. I want you to tell them
to call the police.
I’m sure there will be a lot of people
that already know about that easter egg. And
honestly, quite a few of the eggs in this
movie are pretty common knowledge because
of the nature of Scream; it’s basically
a movie that’s so loaded with references
and nods, that it’s going to attract people
who already know about that stuff.
On Things You Missed™, I try to stick to
things you might have missed, that’s why
it’s called that, if you didn’t know.
However, if I leave out the ones that everyone
knows about then there are gonna be people
in the comments complaining that I missed stuff.
So let’s just go through the ones
that I think are more obvious real quick and
get them out of the way.
Billy climbs through Sidney's window and startles
her, just like Glen did to Nancy in A Nightmare
on Elm Street. Sheriff Burke is played by
the actor who plays the police officer in
Nightmare on Elm St. Tatum’s number 10 crop
top is very similar to a shirt worn by Glen
in A Nightmare on Elm St. Principal Himbry
has the following conversation with the janitor.
– [Himbry] Damn little sh*ts
– [Janitor] What’d you call me?
– [Himbry] Not you Fred.
That’s director Wes Craven cameoing
as Fred, which is short for Freddy, because
he’s dressed up like Freddy Krueger from
A Nightmare On Elm Street.
– [Rizzo] Frederick! Freddie!
When Ghostface pins down Sidney, he cocks
his head just like Michael Myers, and the
movie makes a point to show that scene during
Stu’s party. Sidney refers to the town of
Woodsboro under curfew as The Town That Dreaded
Sundown. And Randy, who yells at the TV to
warn Jamie Lee Curtis about the threat behind
her, also has a threat behind him.
– [Randy] Jamie, look behind you. Look behind
you.
The actor that plays Randy is also named
Jamie, and he’s being watched in a similar
manner by Kenny, the news camera guy.
And speaking of people named Jamie, Sidney
at one point escapes from the attic out onto
the roof like Jamie from Halloween 4.
I think those are all the more well known
easter eggs, so let's get into the fun stuff:
the less obvious ones.
When Billy sneaks into Sid’s room, he tells
her he was watching the Exorcist on TV, with
all the good parts cut out, and it made him
think of their relationship. From this point,
they continue to reference back to this idea
that their relationship is like a movie. After
Sid’s close call with Ghostface, a reporter
asks her…
–[Reporter] So how does it feel to be almost brutally
butchered? People want to know, they have a right to know.
And this is a cameo by Linda Blair, she
played Regan in The Exorcist 23 years earlier.
If you’re listening closely during this
Sidney and Billy scene, you’ll notice that
there is a song playing in the background.
It’s an acoustic cover of Don’t Fear The
Reaper by Blue Oyster Cult. A song that I
like, but I am starting to get a little tired
of hearing in movies and TV. But I’ll save
that rant for a future video, because here,
there might be a good reason for it: it’s
the same song that Laurie Strode and Annie
Brackett listen to in the car in Halloween.
And as I’ve said many times already, Halloween
is the template that Scream builds off of.
There could also be a second meaning here,
the Ghostface costume is essentially a depiction
of a grim reaper. The name of the costume
itself in universe is “Father Death.”
The next day the school is buzzing with rumors
and news crews trying to capitalize on the story.
We first see one of our main characters,
Gail Weathers, in the background of an establishing shot.
Even though we don’t end up going
towards her here, the neon green outfit in
a sea of dull wardrobe colors draws the eye
and lets us know she’s important. It’s
It's like in a video game where it will only let
you target characters that you can actually
talk to. That’s good filmmaking. It’s
also kind of a preview of how the movie ends,
but Gail has a bloody lip and a red dress.
During school that day, each student is called
into the office for interrogation. There’s
a chart on the wall that details which teachers
are in which classrooms each period. Most
of the teachers’ names are crew reference
easter eggs. Almost all of these refer to
people in the art department, who would have
been the ones to put these decorations on
set. They include carpenter Art Williams,
local lead person Kenny Montante, additional
set decorator Debra Echard, leadman Richard
Lambert, set dresser Josh Elliot, art department
production assistant Charlene Bar, art director
David Lubin, driver Ben Davis, and set decorator
Michele Poulik, probably a very unfortunate
name to have to grow up with.
We actually see Michele put her name into
the movie a couple times. In the hallway,
there’s a poster advertising Michelle Palik
for President, a deliberate misspelling of
her name. In the bathroom, there’s some
graffiti that says “Michele + Bob 4 ever”,
using the same unconventional spelling as
the set decorator.
Because of her situation with her mom being
killed a year prior, the media attention is
very familiar for Sid.
– [Sidney] You know the police and reporters
and everything, it’s like Deja Vu all over again.
That’s a redundant statement. That would
be like saying I went on a side-tangent. Or,
if I commented on Scream’s acute self-awareness.
One of the things Scream does to stay interesting
is play with our expectations. Pay attention
to the music sting that happens when Sidney
opens the closet door.
(ghostly whisper in music)
Using typical horror movie logic, the audience
can expect that this means a scare is about
to happen. It’s the perfect setup for that
classic refrigerator door scare, but when
she closes it, nobody is there. This also
establishes the idea that the closet should
be empty, making it even better when Ghostface
busts out of it 5 minutes later.
– [Ghostface] With the murders and all,
it’s like
right out of a horror movie or something.
We see more of that aforementioned self-awareness
as Sidney mocks horror movies, saying they
are all the same.
–[Sidney]  …some stupid killer stalking some big
breasted girl who can’t act, who’s always
running up the stairs when she should be going
out the front door, it’s insulting.
…only for her to do just that when she
can’t figure out how to unlock the front door.
I always love this next part. She calls
the police on her PC, connects to someone
seconds later, and the cops are at the door
in 46 seconds. Take notes Uber Eats.
So Sidney is saved by the time Tatum shows
up in her red VW Beetle. I don’t know 100%
if this is an intentional reference, but since
it’s Scream, I’ll just assume that it is.
This is the car that Jack Torrance drives
in the novel version of The Shining. It appears
in Stanley Kubrick’s film adaptation as
well, as the car that’s been crushed by
an overturned truck, Kubrick’s way of saying,
screw you King, I’m not gonna follow the book.
Of course, there is a more obvious Stephen
King reference later on.
–[Billy] Corn syrup, same stuff they use for pig’s
blood in Carrie.
Tatum also goes with to the police station,
where they get some info from Sidney.
Her brother Dewey tries to get her to respect
him while he’s in uniform in front of his
superior officer.
– [Dewey] He’s my superior.
– [Tatum] The janitor’s your superior.
Which is true… on the film set, since
Wes Craven, the director, plays the janitor.
Technically he’s David Arquette’s boss.
Billy’s name is cleared when Stu calls Sidney
again using the Ghostface voice while Billy
is still in custody. Sheriff Burke is no L.
I don’t even know if he’s on the level
of Randy, to be honest.
–[Randy] He’s got killer printed all over his
forehead.
Which is exactly where Sidney shoots him
at the end of the movie.
Randy is portrayed as the biggest buff in
the story. He works at the video store, and
knows all the rules about horror movies. We
see these rules referenced time and time again
by the killer on the phone, and that leads
us to see Randy as a prime suspect.
–[Randy] I’m the first to admit it. If this were
a scary movie, I’d be the prime suspect.
However, there may be someone who is an
equally big movie buff, and that is Stu Macher.
In fact, there are a couple clues that link
him to the video store just as much as Randy.
The store has these two posters on display.
The one on the left is a poster for the 1993
film Mother’s Boys, starring Jamie Lee Curtis.
Stu is a big fan of Jamie Lee. All the videos
he rents for his party have her in them.
–[Sidney] Terror train. Prom night. How come Jamie
Lee Curtis is in all of these movies?
–[Randy] She’s the Scream Queen.
– [Stu] And with a set of lungs like that, she should be.
On the right is a poster for the band
Greenjelly. This same poster can be seen when
Sidney runs into Stu’s room to escape Ghostface,
so I think it just serves as a link to show
us that Stu probably spends more time than
we’d expect at the video store.
At this point in the movie, there are a few innuendoes as well.
Tatum tells Sidney her intimacy issues will thaw out with time as she removes a case of popsicles from the freezer.
This basically tells us that Sidney's
getting ready to lose her virginity.
Then there’s this… meme-worthy moment.
Our eyes are drawn to a certain part of the
frame, which of course is Tatum’s lungs.
Then our eyes are drawn to another part of
the frame. This spiral pattern just kind of
draws you in, it’s like a hypnosis. Even
though we don’t see her having sex, we know
that Tatum falls victim to rule number one,
because her death occurs when she gets stuck
in the pet door in the garage, and she’s
unable to get out because her tits and cheeks
are too big.
Also the song playing when she enters the
garage is "Drop Dead Gorgeous" by Republica.
Scream was doing death omen songs four years
before Final Destination came out.
That night, Sidney does end up giving up the
v-card to Billy, and Ghostface breaks in and
appears to kill him, but obviously we know
it was just corn syrup. The was Stu cleans
up off the knife is interesting to me. The
motion almost kind of resembles taking off
a condom, and for Sidney, it comes immediately
as a post-sex act.
And Stu later admits that he did have a thing
for Sidney, which she responds to by pushing
the TV onto him and saying
–[Sidney] In your dreams.
(Stu SCREAMing; source of movie title)
It’s kind of a karma moment, because
Stu was the one to laugh in Randy’s face
when he asked if he might have a chance with
Sidney.
After everything we’ve been through, it’s
only fitting that the action ends with one
last meta-horror trope.
– [Randy] This is the moment when the supposedly
dead killer comes back to life. For one last scare.
–[Billy] Augh!
(screams)
(gunshot)
–[Sidney] Not in my movie.
What do you mean not in my movie? It literally
just happened.
Before we can end this video, there is one
more thing I want to talk about.
(THUNDER)
♪ Upbeat Music ♪
The big surprise in Scream, that again, like
the camerawork and writing choices that I
brought up in this video, uses our horror-genre
expectations against us, is the fact that
there are two killers instead of the usual
one that we get in most slasher movies.
The clues were there all along. In the Casey
Becker scene, one Ghostface breaks into the
house and runs straight to the front door.
We don’t know why at the time, but it was
to let his accomplice inside. You can actually
spot that the door is now open when Casey’s
parents get home.
At the fountain, Stu explains to Sidney how
you gut someone, Billy makes eye contact with
him and says,
–[Billy] Hey, it’s called tact you f*ckrag.
We assume that he’s standing up for
his girlfriend, but he might actually be trying
to shut Stu up before he says too much and
gives them away.
This might be obvious, but Sidney first suspects
Billy when she sees the cell phone fall out
of his pocket. If he has a cell phone, why
does he need to come sneak through the window
to talk to her?
Then there are multiple instances of Billy
just acting sus. Like when Sidney admits that
she doesn’t think he’s guilty, he keeps
trying to convince her.
–[Billy] You still think it’s me?
–[Sidney] No I don’t, it’s just somebody was there, Billy. Someone tried to kill me.
–[Billy] I know, I know, the cops said I scared him away. It wasn’t me Sid.
–[Sidney] I know. He called me again last night at Tatum’s house.
–[Billy] See? Couldn’t have been me, I was in jail.
And this is obviously him trying too hard
to drive home the point that the second Ghostface
call exonerates him.
Stu does a similar thing at the fountain.
– [Stu] No, I didn’t kill anybody.
– [Billy] Nobody said you did.
Then at the school, there are a
couple of pranksters who run around in Ghostface
masks, and they find themselves sitting in
the principal’s office. One is wearing blue
flannel with a white t-shirt underneath, which
is what Billy wears to the party, and the
other wearing a muted long sleeve shirt, not
the same color, but very similar in style
to what Stu has on at the party.
Now I want you to look very closely, right
here…
(jumpscare)
Had to get that one last scare in.
(THUNDER)
Throughout Scream 2, we see a few glimpses
of the movie Stab! which is essentially the
in-universe version of Scream 1. Each character’s
Stab! counterpart is played by a known actor
from our world, and in the case of Sidney,
that actress is Tori Spelling, which is playing
off of a joke from the original Scream.
– [Tatum] Hey, Sid, just think. If they
make a movie about you, who's gonna play you?
–[Dewey] I see you as a young Meg Ryan myself.
–[Sidney] Thanks Dewey, with my luck, they'd cast Tori Spelling.
It’s at one point suggested that the
new killer is trying to make an in real life
sequel to the happenings in Woodsboro from
the year before, and Scream 2 consequently
features many scenes that call back to the
original. To learn the meaning behind the
graffiti, stick around to the end of this
video.
–[Joel] And I’ll be back when you guys start
talking about something a little more Saved
by the Bell ish.
Welcome to Things You Missed. I am Zac
Morris. As I discussed last episode, Scream 1
was a satire on horror movies, so naturally
Scream 2 satirizes sequels. In fact, it openly
acknowledges that they’re usually inferior
to the original… so what’s the deal here?
Did they intentionally make Scream 2 an inferior
movie? In the movie premiere scene, Maureen
gets flack from her fellow movie goers when
she *loudly* encourages the character on screen
to use some common sense.
Scream 2 features previously intelligent characters
doing things that make you want to *ahem*
Scream at the television, like splitting up
with a killer in the vicinity, backing up
against a window and going back to unmask
someone when you should just run.
– [Randy] The way I see it, someone’s
out to make a sequel. You know, cash in on
all the movie murder hoopla.
…says Randy, as he enjoys his
product placement. Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
In the first Scream, I talked about how the
movie started by pulling a page from Alfred
Hitchcock’s Psycho by killing off it's poster
girl. This time, the poster features two more
big stars, Jada Pinkett and Sarah Michelle
Gellar. Jada’s character Maureen is the
second to die after her boyfriend, just like
Casey, and Sarah’s character Cici is third.
Also, speaking of pulling a page from Psycho,
the opening scene of Stab adds a part where
Casey goes into the shower. The shot of the
tap turning on is the same shot from Psycho.
The rest of the scene is pretty accurate to
what we saw in Scream, including the conversation,
which begs the question: how would the creators
of Stab
know what transpired that night unless…
one of the participants was actually still
alive?
Scream 1 used Halloween as a template, a movie
that everybody knows and can understand how
it’s being satirized. But Scream 2 doesn’t
really offer an equivalent. However, Stab
acts as an in-universe stand-in for Scream
1, and we’ve seen something similar in the
Halloween franchise. In Halloween III, we
see that the original Halloween is just a
movie in that universe. Halloween III is also
a famously panned sequel, but other than that,
there aren’t really any other similarities.
Scream had become famous and there were already
movies in production trying to imitate it.
So the challenge was on for Scream 2 to try
to be the best imitator. While the first Scream
made its gimmick apparent by having the killers
quiz Casey on scary movies while being in
a scary movie, Scream 2 tells us that these
movie fans are about to be in a movie of their
own by using screen direction. ‘Stab Casey’
is seen running to the left towards a door,
and then we cut to Phil going left through
a door himself. This link is the director’s
way of telling us that he’s about to be
a victim too.
We hear the song Red Right Hand by Nick Cave
and the Bad Seeds twice in this movie. In
the first one it played during the curfew
lockup montage, and in 2, we hear it right
as Stab is beginning and as the Delta Lambda
Zeta party disperses, perhaps another link
to tell us that the movie is leaking into
reality.
There are a lot of instances where things
in Scream 2 fill the role for material from
the first one. For example, Sidney’s college
mascot is the Wildcats, a less specific version
of the Panthers, which was her high school
mascot. It plays into the idea that we have
copycat killers, just like how the initial
3 victims share a name with the first three
victims in Woodsboro. Sidney once again gets
unwanted attention from the press because
of her past. The scene where Cici is attacked
at her sorority home is just like the scene
of Sidney being attacked at her actual home.
And just like Scream 1, Ghostface pops out
from a closet by the stairs. I wonder if the
fact that he hides “under the stairs”
is a Wes Craven reference. Cici’s immediate
reaction is to then run up the stairs, just
like high school Sidney said she would.
–[Sidney] Some stupid killer stalking some big breasted
girl who can’t act who’s always running
up the stairs when she should be going out
the front door.
The ice cream scene is the new video store
scene. In the video store scene, Randy directly
determines who one of the killers is by accusing
Billy, who fires back by asking…
–[Billy] How do we know you’re not the killer?
And Randy admits that if this were a scary
movie, he would, in fact, be a prime suspect.
This time, he correctly identifies Mickey
as one of the killers.
–[Randy] The freaky Tarantino film student.
But also concedes that he would likely
be a suspect on the same grounds.
– [Randy] But if he’s a suspect, so am I.
Worth noting in this scene, he’s also
kind of on the right track when it comes to
the second killer. He brings up Mrs. Voorhees
as proof that the killer could be a female.
Like Mrs. Voorhees from Friday the 13th, the
killer is the mom of another killer.
Randy’s other suspect is Gale Weathers.
–[Randy] That’s what reporters do, Dewey. They
stage the news.
He’s got the right idea, but he’s
got the wrong reporter. History repeats itself
later in the movie when Gale and Dewey team
up, and Gale makes an important discovery
while they're hooking up. In the original
it’s Neil Prescott’s car, in the sequel
it’s Mickey’s tapes. The killer is once
again behind Randy.
–[Randy] Look behind you.
Dewey gets stabbed in the back again.
Gale blocks the door to the recording studio
so that Ghostface can only reach in and flail.
It’s like Sidney in her room. Mickey reveals
himself as the killer using a familiar line.
–[Mickey] Surprise Sidney!
– …just like Stu did during the last 20
minutes of Scream.
–[Stu] Surprise Sidney!
– At the end, Sidney buries one into Mrs.
Loomis’s forehead just like she had to her
son, and it all ends with Cotton foreshadowing
the next Stab film.
– [Cotton] I’ll tell you one thing. It
will make a hell of a movie.
– But there is one easter egg that even
I wouldn’t have found if not for this retrospective
documentary.
(THUNDER)
♪ Dreadful Music ♪
I’m sure you noticed the way Ghostface wipes
off the knife in Scream 2. It’s a signature
move established by Stu in the first movie.
I wanted to bring it up though, because in
my video on the first film, I tried to, as
I do, figure out what the subtext might be
behind this. However, in the 2011 retrospective
Still Screaming, Dane Farwell, the stunt actor
in that scene offers a simpler explanation.
–[Dane] It’s a direct cut to me running through
the hall with a clean knife. Wes just thought
for two seconds and said, “We’ll wipe
the knife off on camera.”
– Another thing I talked about in my first
video was relevant cameo appearances, and
those seem to have been given special attention
here in 1997.
Director of Photography Peter Deming plays
the ‘Popcorn Boy’. Screenwriter Kevin
Williamson is the interviewer on “Current
Edition”. I never would have noticed this
on my own, but Matthew Lillard, who plays
Stu in Scream, used 2% of his power to make
a background cameo at the party scene, which
thankfully for me, he brought up in the retrospective,
otherwise I never would have known it was
him.
–[Matthew] One day I was just hanging out and they
were like ‘come walk in the back of the
party scene’.
– And director Wes Craven makes another
appearance, this time as a doctor at the hospital
scene. That one I actually found out about
from a fan site, which is coincidentally also
called “Still Screaming.” The best cameo
though is this one, from Lev Shrieber’s dog.
What a boy. There are a bunch of other
cameos, but on Things You Missed, I’m only
interested in ones that have some kind of
significance or something to do with the movie.
After a film class discussion on sequels and
imitators of movie killers, Gale brushes off
the idea of audience safety being important.
–[Gale] Are you kidding me? It’d be stupid to
pull this movie. All this free press they’re
gonna have huge numbers this weekend.
You either die a hero, or live long
enough to see yourself become the villain.
Despite this movie’s concept: being a take-off
of horror sequels, we aren’t bombarded with
movie references like we were in Scream. Instead,
there’s another theme that the finale centers
itself around: theatre. Sidney is a theatre
major and has a prominent role in the production
of Agamemnon, which is advertised all over
the campus.
– [Gus] Cassandra is one of the great tragic
visionaries of literature. She saw it all
coming. The wars, the murder, the madness.
She knew she was cursed. It was her fate and
she embraced it.
– This might be a comparison between two
unlikely subjects to be paired, horror movie
final girls and greek mythology. One of the
things that audiences tend to find ridiculous
about sequels is the fact that the same characters
get themselves into trouble again. It always
seems like a huge coincidence that only exists
to extend the franchise. That’s why in a
lot of long running franchises, there’s
some kind of curse that keeps the killer coming
back again and again.
The character Sidney plays in Agamemnon is
Cassandra, who is literally cursed by the
Greek God Apollo. In the case of Scream, it’s
obviously not like a magic curse, but rather
that Sidney is cursed by the publicity of
the horrible things that have happened to
her.
I do think it’s significant that their whole
culture on campus revolves around these sororities,
or as they are sometimes called, Greek Life.
In the car crash scene, there’s some graffiti
of the Greek letters representing the sorority
where the party took place earlier, Delta
Lambda Zeta, along with text in English that
says “stab this”. But the Greek letters
are crossed out in red, and this is the scene
where their pledge, Hallie, gets herself crossed
off by Mickey.
The movie’s climax takes place on the stage
where the “Fall of Troy” set is still
up. This is where Ghostface attacks her on
more than one occasion. The Greek vs. the
Trojan so to speak. At the end she actually
uses her Greek letters, given to her by her
boyfriend to protect her, to attack Mickey,
and ultimately get away.
The play that she’s in is Agamemnon, which
like Stab, is the first chapter of a trilogy.
Scream was a trilogy from 2000-2011.
(rock music)
– [Mickey] Empire Strikes Back. It was a
better story. Improved effects.
– [Randy] Not a sequel, part of a trilogy,
completely planned.
– In Scream, I think I pointed out like
20 different Nightmare on Elm Street references,
but Scream 2 seems to just have one, when
Cotton is arrested by Sidney’s bodyguards
in the library we see a book called Our Dreaming
Mind, which deals with the science of sleep
and dreams, much like how Nancy visits a sleep
disorder clinic to try fix her Freddy Fr--
(BEEP)
(laughing) to try to fix her Freddy Freeman
problem...
(BEEP)
...to try to fix her Freddy Krueger problem.
For a minute, I thought this was Freddy’s
iconic sweater in Sid’s dorm room, but when
I actually compared them, I realized they’re
not the same. I had the same thing happen
in Sid’s room when I analyzed the first
Scream, I thought this was Chucky’s sweater,
but eventually realized the colors don’t
match. Scream 2 has a girl that looks kind
of like Chucky, but again, the colors don’t
match.
As I did for the first movie, I want to wrap
up by talking about some of the evidence about
who the killers are, some of which you might
have missed.
(THUNDER)
♪ Upbeat Music ♪
First up we’ve got Cici’s sorority house,
where we can confirm that there are once again,
two killers because you can still hear one
Ghostface talking on the phone as the other
sneaks through the front door in the background.
During certain chase scenes, we hear Ghostface
grunting. Sometimes it sounds male…
(male grunting sounds)
– … and at other times, the sound is female.
(female grunting sounds)
– But when speaking on the phone, we can’t
make this determination because of the voice
changer. When Sidney gets a Ghostface call
from Debra Salt aka Mrs. Loomis at the sorority
house, she hears this…
– [Caller] Hello Sidney. Remember me?
– …suggesting that it’s someone from
Sidney’s past, like her late ex-boyfriend’s
mom.
And from a filmmaking standpoint, when you
make a sequel, you have to include enough
information so that even audiences who haven’t
seen the first one can keep up. We only see
two scenes from Stab, the opening and this
scene, which reminds us that Billy’s Mom
left him and his Dad. They only reason to
cut away from the scene we’re in and show
that part is if that information is going
to somehow be important. Like if Billy’s
Mom were to, for example, come back.
Debra also suspiciously manages to get to
the scene of the crime at the sorority house
where Cici was attacked and at the film school
where Dewey was attacked before anyone else.
Maybe because she was already there.
But the strongest evidence is actually the
evidence for Mickey being guilty. In class,
he argues for the idea that sequels can be
better than the original. Of course he would
say that. The Windsor murders are his sequel
to the Woodsboro murders.
– [Sidney] You know, I knew this was coming?
I knew this wasn’t over?
– [Mickey] You are not alone Sid.
– Yeah, he would know that this was coming
because he was responsible. The most damning
evidence though is the fact that he always
has his video camera. When Dewey and Gale
go to study their tapes, they see each of
the crime scenes was recorded from Ghostface’s
point of view. The only issue is that he isn’t
the one projecting these tapes. He must have
given them to Mrs. Loomis at some point, because
he was planning on getting caught so he could
use the trial to try to blame the movies for
his actions.
OK, I take back what I said. The most damning
evidence against Mickey is the fact that we
can see him right here through the eyeholes
of the Ghostface mask.
Scream 2 was famously rewritten during production
because the ending leaked on the internet,
so the fact that we have all these setups
is kind of impressive. We’re mostly all
in agreement that Scream 1 is superior, and
I think the very idea that the sequel’s
villain could just be switched like that is
kind of a testament to it being a weaker story.
However, with all of that being said, I guess
Cotton was going to be one of the villains originally?
And I’m sort of glad that didn’t happen because his redemption at the end is one of the best parts.
And it sets for Scream 3.
If you’re a Kevin Smith fan, you may already
be familiar with Jay and Silent Bob’s cameo
in Scream 3, but you might not know the backstory
behind it. Jay and Silent Bob are a pair of
characters that first appeared in Kevin Smith’s
1994 movie, Clerks, which is prominently displayed
at the video store in the original Scream.
Jay and Bob would become recurring characters
who show up in many Kevin Smith films that
are part of his View Askewniverse, and as
a thank you for the free advertising in Scream,
Kevin Smith and Scream director Wes Craven
decided to exchange cameos in each other’s
movies. So, Jay and Silent Bob show up in
Scream 3, and the following year, Wes shows
up in Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back, where
he plays Wes Craven the director of Scream
4, a decade before Wes would actually create
Scream 4.
In addition to that, Cotton Weary’s apartment
in the opening of Scream 3 contains a copy
of Chasing Amy, which is also part of the
View Askewniverse.
The scene with Jay and Silent Bob also contains
a couple other cameos, which are pretty much
only findable thanks to the retrospective
documentary Still Screaming, which points
out a cameo from Wes Craven as the man with
a video camera, and Scream 3’s casting director
Lisa Beach as the tour guide.
To learn how Scream 3 may have had a second
killer who died before being revealed, stick
around to the end of this video.
(Thunder)
In Scream, movies don’t create psychos,
movies make psychos more creative. In Scream 2
movies are a scapegoat for someone who
is planning to be a killer. Scream 3 reverses
this and has the killer make the movie, creating
his own lore every step of the way.
Welcome to Things You Missed. Wanting to capitalize
on the hype train created by Scream 1 and 2
producers decided to go ahead without screenwriter
Kevin Williamson, by replacing him with Ehren Kruger.
Really? The creator of A Nightmare
On Elm Street is working with a guy named Kruger?
– [Jennifer] Stage name.
–[Bianca] You should talk, Judy Jurgenstern.
– [Group] OHHHHH!!!!!
– Sidney Prescott has become a crisis hotline
counselor, and she also takes on a stage name
of sorts, going by Laura to her callers. She’s
unknowingly following in the footsteps of
her mother, who used the name Rina Reynolds
while working in Hollywood. There’s a running
theme of pseudonyms in Scream 3. Most of our
main characters are actors who are just as
likely to respond to their character names
as their actual names, to the point that it
becomes kind of a joke.
–[Jennifer] Not “Sidney”, Sidney. Like I’m “Gale”
and she’s Gale.
– Obviously, it’s more than just a joke
though, it’s important to the plot, because
Roman’s changing of his last name to Bridger
is what helps disguise his true identity as
Sidney’s brother and the killer.
Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
(knives slashing)
♪ Dreadful Music ♪
As with Screams 1 and 2, the opening shows
the slaying of a couple, only this time, we
recognize one of the victims, it’s Cotton
Weary and his girlfriend. Cotton is complaining
that he is only given a cameo in Stab 3, which
is basically his experience in Scream 3 -- despite
being a big part of the second movie, they
kill him off right away in this one.
One the criticisms of turning Scream into
a franchise was that it would become the very
thing that the original Scream was satirizing,
and we see this intentionally, or not intentionally
in Scream 3’s opening. In the last film,
Stab 1 attempted to recreate the opening of
Scream, the death of Casey Becker. But certain
things are embellished for Hollywood, like
how they add a shower scene which seems to
have no purpose other than showing a little
skin.
So Scream 3’s opening literally does that,
in the form of Cotton’s girlfriend getting
out of the shower. There’s even a shot of
Christine’s towel dropping by her feet,
very similar to Casey’s bathrobe in Stab.
–[Sarah] The whole shower thing’s been done!
Vertigo. Hello?
– It’s not Vertigo, it’s Psycho. As
we have discussed many times on this show.
Then, Christine even channels her inner
Casey Becker herself when she kicks Ghostface
to get away.
Scream 2’s opening was all about the Stab
movie premiere, so there’s a slight nod
to that as well, when Cotton is frantically
driving home, he nearly hits a bus with a
Stab 2 advertisement on back.
This next one might not be a reference, this
might just be Cotton being entirely focused
on saving his girlfriend, but he leaves his
car door open as he goes inside, much like
Bob Simms in Halloween, who was also probably
focused on one thing entirely. As you know
if you’ve seen Scream, Halloween is basically
considered the big one, and is referenced
all the time. But not that much in Scream
3. Although there is the one part where Sidney
hears her mother’s voice telling her she’ll
protect her from the Boogeyman. The Boogeyman
is a pseudonym for Michael Myers in the Halloween
films.
Ghostface tries to pressure Cotton into revealing
the location of Sidney Prescott before offing
him, and then we see Sidney living a secluded
life with her dog. By her door there’s a
Fall of Troy poster advertising the play she
was in in college, Agamemnon. Does that mean
she actually went through with being in the
play after defeating Mickey and Debbie on
it’s stage? That’s dedication.
She also continues to wear the Greek letters
given to her by her boyfriend when the murders
were happening in the last movie. Can you
really blame her? He was the best guy she
ever dated.
The next character we meet is Gale Weathers,
who is giving a speech about being a journalist
lady. A woman in the crowd is wearing a #81
jersey. Not many people know this, but Scream
1996 was not the first… or last… slasher
movie to be called Scream. The original was
a 1981 film. I have not seen it, but according
to the Letterboxd ratings, it is not very
good.
This scene also has the best extra. This lady
is REALLY into Gale’s speech. This speech
is part of a lecture series called FW Bestor
Lecture Series: Faces of Journalism, named
after the movie’s art department coordinator
Claudia Bestor.
Just like the last two movies, Sidney is at
home, when she sees bad news on the TV that
involves her and her past.
As we’re first introduced to Sunrise Studios,
where most of this movie takes place, we hear
the song Red Right Hand by Nick Cave and the
Bad Seeds, which by this point is more or
less the Scream theme song, this is our fourth
time hearing it, and the end credits would
be the fifth, although that one is a special
Scream 3 version meant to close out the trilogy.
Stab 3’s subtitle is “Return to Woodsboro”,
and this phrase keeps finding new meaning
throughout the movie. It’s actually a leftover
from Kevin Williamson’s original outline
for the script, that he planned after writing
Scream 2, but most of it was not used for
what would become Scream 3. We would symbolically
return to Woodsboro immediately, because they’re
shooting on the Woodsboro set. Sidney would
return to Woodsboro when she is later chased
through this set. Later still, the focus of
the story is brought back to Woodsboro when
we learn new information about the motivations
of Billy and Stu. And the movie would end
with everyone returning Woodsboro, or at least
what appears to be Woodsboro to join Sidney
at her secluded home. But this first scene
on the Woodsboro set contains more depth than
what meets the eye.
(Thunder)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
When we meet Roman, the director of Stab 3,
he’s busy making a case for keeping the
production going after Cotton’s death.
– [Roman] Hire more security, hire the national
guard, just don’t kill the movie.
– Which is funny, because he literally would
kill the movie, at least for the time being,
by killing everyone in it. He’s seen arguing
with a studio executive played by Roger Corman,
who tells him that violence in cinema is kind
of a no-no right now. Which is also a little
joke, because Roger Corman is a well known
horror producer and director. He literally
made movies such as Night of the Blood Beast.
A Bucket of Blood. Bloody Mama. Battle of
Blood Island. Blood Bath. A remake of A Bucket
of Blood.
But his concern over gory movies in 1999 was
very relevant, because Stab 3 is the in-universe
stand-in for Scream 3, and Scream 3 was going
through the same problems at this time thanks
to the Columbine Massacre, the worst high
school shooting of the millenium.
The Columbine Massacre was carried out by
two high school seniors, and that is really
only similarity to Scream that exists, but
that didn’t stop people who were already
against horror movies.
–[Wes] Everybody that didn’t like horror films
that was in a position of power, came after
the studios.
– [Zac] Columbine happened in April 1999.
Scream 3 started shooting in July, so there
was a lot of pressure from the studio to limit
the gore, which is why we see less of it in
this movie. According to Matthew Lillard,
he was already paid to appear in Scream 3
as the returning villain Stu Macher, but Columbine
put an end to those plans. Wes Craven attempted
to make sure the cultural context was not
forgotten, by sneaking in this article about
Columbine into the scene where Sidney looks
through her file at the police station.
The other articles in this file are just nonsense.
Look at this one. “The local police chief,
the first official commissioned by the city
with the search committed in the name of the
parents. The shadowy suspect, faces 121 charges
of murder, kidnapping, arms, smuggling, fraud
and theft. 'His plea is he hadn’t committed
these offenses.' said the parents’ attorney,
'we will find the Megan at all cost.'"
When Gale, that is, the real Gale, shows up
on set, she’s hit by that wave of dreadful
familiarity.
–[Gale] Deja Voodoo.
– Her misuse of the term déjà vu, right
outside of Sidney’s house, calls back to
Sidney’s own misuse of the phrase in Scream
1. The nostalgia does not end there though,
because the new Gale, aka Jennifer, is dressed
more like the old Gale.
But what happens next is not all old and familiar.
Gale runs into Dewey, who has become an advisor
for the movie. When these two met in Scream
2, Dewey was upset with how Gale portrayed
him in her book. Now, Dewey has turned the
tables on her, and Gale is upset about how
he’s portraying her in Stab 3.
In my previous Scream analysis videos, I pointed
out Wes Craven’s easter eggs to his other
major horror franchise, A Nightmare on Elm
Street. We don’t really get that much in
the third one, but there is this one tiny
nightmare scene involving Sidney, where she
sees her dead mother come to the window.
If we’re being honest though, the reference
points a lot more towards Salem’s Lot than
it does towards Freddy Krueger.
The next day, Sarah Darling, who plays the
character Candy in Stab, has a meeting with
Roman at the production office.
–[Sarah] I’m Candy, the chick who gets killed
second. I’m only in two scenes.
– Like Cotton’s gripes about his character,
the complaint about her screen time could
also apply to her role in Scream 3; she’s
only in 2 scenes. There’s also another 1:1
parallel later, where the police mention that
there are three versions of the Stab 3 script,
in order to try to keep the ending off the
internet -- the exact same approach used for
Scream 3. And then there’s the romance between
Dewey and Gale. This time, rather than art
imitating life, life would imitate art. These
two got married for realsies right before
they started shooting.
Anyway, during the line reading, Roman goes
off the script, and then claims there’s
a new version.
–[Roman] It’s not just a new script, it’s a
new movie.
–[Sarah] What movie?
–[Roman] My movie.
– Although we don’t know it yet, she’s
speaking to the real Roman, and he’s telling
the truth. By killing the people involved
in Stab 3, he’s creating the lore for Stab
3. He’s creating his movie.
Candy is the successor to Tatum in Scream,
and her death closely resembles Tatum’s.
Ghostface chases her into the prop room where,
among all the movie props, is a fridge. Remember,
Tatum went to the garage to get drinks from
the fridge. She’s punched through a door
where she’s left hanging on her stomach,
and this is where Ghostface get her. She dies
in the exact same position that Tatum died
in in the pet flap.
While Gale and Dewey are out to lunch to discuss
their past relationship, Gale emphasizes the
importance of leaving him alone to go on the
sequel to 60 minutes, claiming she could have
been the next Diane Sawyer. It’s a bit of
a Scream 2 reference, Diane Sawyer was the
journalist that Cotton most wanted to be interviewed
on to gain fame.
Back on the movie set, we have maybe our most
obvious set of crew reference easter eggs
yet on the director’s chairs. Yes, they
are called that. This one’s for Peter Deming,
the Director of Photography, this one belongs
to Sheila Waldron, the script supervisor and
there’s one for Bruce Alan Miller, the production
designer.
That evening, the cast gathers for the depressing
wrap party at Jennifer’s house, where the
killing continue with her security guard,
and Roman continues to quote unquote write
his movie by literally sending in script pages
telling them what to do via fax. Uhh, if you
don’t know what fax is, look it up.
The house blows up, taking out Tom, aka: the
new Dewey, and the old Gale punches the new
Gale in the face, this is yet another twist
on the Scream tradition, of Ms. Weathers getting
a facefull of knuckles in each film.
The characters end up at the police station
where they’re finally reunited with Sidney.
One nice detail at the station is the display
of movie posters and books about film. It’s
like Randy suggested in Scream 1, that the
cops should study movies to save time.
Speaking of Randy, he makes his return, in
the form of a post-mortem video message, which
he would use to communicate a few new horror
movie rules.
(cinematic impact)
– [Randy] True trilogies are all about going
back to the beginning and discovering something
that wasn’t true from the get-go. Godfather,
Jedi, all revealed something that we thought
was true, that wasn’t true.
– This was not his first time referencing
the original Star Wars trilogy, we saw him
mention it in Scream 2, and it wouldn't be
long before it came up again.
The two Gales meet the Sunrise Studios archivist,
who is played by Carrie Fisher,
aka, Princess Leia in Star Wars.
–[Bianca] I was up for Princess Leia. I was this
close. So who gets it? The one who sleeps
with George Lucas.
– She also shares something in common with
Sidney, her trilogy also involves the surprise
twist where she discovers someone is her brother.
They pull out the file for Maureen Prescott,
who at the time was going by Rina Reynolds.
At the bottom of her resume, we can see that
she started her acting career in theatre,
just as her daughter would go on to do. One
of the plays she was in was even called I
Want To Scream. So they’ve got a whole little
family involved in the dramatic arts. Maureen
with her acting in plays and horror films;
Roman, the director; and Sidney, the live
performer.
If Candy’s death was a callback to Tatum,
this scene where Sidney is chased through
the movie set is a repeat of her own scene
in Scream, right down to her screwing herself
by locking herself in with Ghostface at the
front door. There’s also another similarity.
In Scream, she calls the police using this
program on her computer, and Dewey immediately
shows up at her door. In Scream 3, she literally
just yells out for Dewey and he comes running
because he’s already at the studio.
The cops show up and we see this one new cop
named “J West”. This is the last crew
reference easter egg, it’s a reference to
the assistant production coordinator John
Burton West.
After discovering Maureen worked in the movies,
Dewey and the Gales confront the producer
John Milton, who basically tells them that
he held these parties back in the day where
industry bigwigs took advantage of actresses,
and he basically turned a blind eye to this
illegal activity.
If you’ve followed the entertainment industry
recently, this might sound familiar. In 2018
film producer Harvey Weinstein was arrested
as many allegations came out against him,
some of which dated back to the 1970s, the
very same time period that John Milton claimed
to have these parties. Could this be a coincidence?
Maybe not.
From my understanding, Weinstein got away
with this for as long as he did because he
targeted small time actresses. They did not
take legal action because they were afraid
they’d be blacklisted from the industry,
since Harvey had contacts with all of Hollywood.
For example, two actresses up for parts in
Lord of the Rings lost their roles simply
because Weinstein told Peter Jackson that
they were a “nightmare to work with.”
That’s the kind of influence that he had.
But with the advent of the internet and social
media, the victims were able to discover that
they were not the only ones. There were a
lot. Like a whole lot. So they came together,
knowing that they couldn’t ALL be blacklisted.
The point of all this is, while they didn’t
get him arrested for many years, there were
rumors about Weinstein’s behavior. So it’s
very possible that Wes Craven may have known
about these rumors and pulled the biggest
power move of all time, by putting a Harvey
Weinstein character in his movie. Which by
the way was produced by Bob and Harvey Weinstein.
But unlike these relatively unknown actresses,
Wes Craven had already made it in Hollywood.
Weinstein couldn’t do anything to him, and
besides, he was already nearing the end of
his career. And despite being the executive
producer, Harvey Weinstein couldn’t really
stop Wes from using Scream 3 to make this
indirect accusation. Because if he order Wes
to change the John Milton scene, he’s just
gonna look guilty.
According to the film’s editor, Patrick
Lussier, in an article on Slate, the only
note to come from the Weinstein brothers at
all, came from Harvey’s brother, Bob, he
just had a note about the ending, which I’ll
get back to later in this video. So Wes had
his boss backed into a corner where he could
not give any notes. It’s got to be one of
the most legendary moves that Wes has ever
made if this, in fact, is not a total, huge
coincidence.
–[Exec] Hollywood is full of criminals whose careers
are flourishing.
–[Roman] I'm not a criminal!
– Yeah, I don’t think it is. And to further
add to the suspicion, some of the accusers
are connected to the Scream franchise. Rosanna
Arquette is the real life sister of David
Arquette, Dewey. And Rose McGowan, who plays
Tatum in Scream, is the onscreen sister of
David Arquette. Angelina Jolie, potentially
has two characters named after her in Scream 3
Jennifer Jolie and Angelina Tyler who says
this:
–[Angelina] I did not f*ck that pig Milton to get
a leading role just to die here with second-rate
celebrities like you two!
– The movie’s climax takes place at a
mansion party where Roman’s birthday is
to be celebrated. While we don’t realize
it at the time, I don’t think it’s any
coincidence that Roman puts his plan into
action on his birthday, the day he became
Maureen Prescott’s bastard child.
The party splits up to explore the mansion
and Jennifer finds herself stuck in a passage
with Ghostface. She sees Dewey on the other
side of this soundproof glass barrier and
struggles to get his attention. This is the
same situation that the real Gale was in in
Scream 2, when she was unable to communicate
with him in the recording studio.
There's another repeat of a Scream 2 situation
in the basement when Roman is knocked out
after falling down the stairs, but his body
blocks the only exit. This is like when Sidney
had to climb over Mickey to escape the crashed
car.
Roman uses his capture of Gale and Dewey to
lure Sidney into the house, but she's prepared
and greets him with her hidden gun. Unfortunately
for her, this is the one time that she didn't
deliver a follow up shot to the head and it
comes back back bite her.
The final confrontation takes place in the
secret screening room where Roman was theoretically
conceived. After revealing himself as the
killer there are a couple more parallels to
Scream 1, the bringing out of a gagged victim
and Roman cocking his head just like Ghostface
when he first pinned down Sidney at her dad’s
house.
After he is defeated, we’re treated to an
epilogue. We see Sidney essentially let her
guard down for the first time since that fateful
phone call a few years ago. Then we see Detective
Kincaid, the cop from LA, who apparently came
back with her? He’s holding a bowl of popcorn
and says they’re about to start a movie.
So the Scream trilogy ends just as it began,
with popcorn and a movie.
I personally think this was supposed to be
the end of the series. By comparing the last
ever Scream scene to the first ever, we see
the changed state of the world, before and
after the defeat of Roman, the driving force
behind all of the bad things that happened
to Sidney in the 1990s. However, having only
one killer doesn’t follow the Scream formula.
There could be one more villain from the production
of Stab 3 who has yet to be taken care of.
(cinematic impact)
♪ Upbeat Music ♪
Earlier in this video I mentioned two darker
topics, Weinstein and Columbine. I stated
that Wes Craven and his editor only received
one note on the film and it came from the
innocent of the two brothers, Bob Weinstein.
His idea was to remove the second Ghostface
to just focus on Roman.
The reason for this, or at least one of the
reasons, may have been teased in the film.
Remember the scene where the producers are
having a discussion with Roman about the future
of the film, emphasizing that stringed instruments
in cinema are a big deal right now? A big
reason for that was Columbine. So the shooting
may have also been part of the reason that
they moved away from the initial concept of
having two killers.
The accomplice was going to be Angelina Tyler,
the woman who was set to play the fictional
version of Sidney in Stab 3. You can still
see remnants of this storyline in the film.
In fact, some fans believe that Angelina is
still canonically the 6th Ghostface, and she
was killed before she ever got the chance
to reveal herself.
Her story is that she won the role in a talent
search, but we later find she did this by
sleeping with the producer.
– [Tom] You gotta be praying this movie
keeps going.
–[Angelina] Of course I am, but not at the expense
of people’s lives.
– [Zac] You either die a hero or live --
There are three main sequences that make Angelina
look guilty. The first is shortly after Jennifer’s
house explodes. She briefly disappears, and
comes down the hill well after everyone else,
almost like she knew where to jump to avoid
taking fall damage. This allows her to completely
miss the altercation with Roman. Dewey asks
her about her whereabouts, and she never actually
answers the question.
– [Angelina] Tom was in the house!
Then, there’s the bathroom scene, which
by the way is setup exactly like the school
bathroom scene in
Scream 1. Sidney discovers her seemingly changing
into the Ghostface costume, but Angelina plays
it off as her wanting to take props as souvenirs
now that the movie is shut down. But what
if this is actually her getting caught, and,
being the actress that she is, talking her
way out of it?
This could also be the reason that Roman decides
to kill her off. He probably figured that
Sidney knew she was guilty, and it was better
to get rid of her before she had the chance
to be arrested and interrogated, where she
could possibly give them both away.
He knew Sidney wouldn’t accuse her immediately
though, because she wouldn’t want a repeat
of Cotton Weary on her conscience, who went
to jail because he was wrongfully accused
by Sid when she wasn’t quite 100% sure.
So I think Angelina makes up an excuse, quickly
scurries away, and goes into the sound stage
to finish putting on the Ghostface costume.
When Sidney goes into the movie set version
of her room, there are clearly two killers
here, someone is pushing on the door, and
then 3 seconds later Ghostface is all the
way on the other side of the room, behind
her in the window.
I think the one in the window is Angelina,
because the shoes we see during the struggle
are the exact same as the ones that Sidney
noticed under the bathroom stall. When the
lights go on, we get a better look at Angelina
wearing these shoes with a black… Skirt?
Uh... I don’t know the terminology for this
piece of clothing, but the loose black fabric
could easily help her blend into the Ghostface
cloak.
And the third sequence where she looks guilty
is Roman’s birthday party. Sure, they appear
to be using the buddy system for safety, but
Roman and Angelina are each one-on-one with
a victim.
Dewey and Gale also poke around and find a
Ghostface mask, cell phone and voice changer,
in a closet. But these are not Roman’s because
he clearly has his own. I can understand having
a backup costume, but why have a second voice
changer?
Angelina was supposed to be with Tyson, but
she disappears, and Roman fakes his death,
just like Billy did. In hindsight, he’s
probably the one who taught Billy to make
that Hollywood level corn syrup mixture.
During the big reveal, Roman even suggests
that he gave Billy pointers on being a killer,
such as having a partner to sell out once
you get caught. This means Roman probably
also had a disposable partner.
When we last see Angelina, she’s frantically
trying to leave the house. Could it be that
at this point, she knows Roman is done with
her, and she’s now fearing for her life?
Or is this just part of the act? We don’t
actually see her die, she just gets stabbed
in the shoulder, and dragged out of view.
It is awfully inconclusive for a Scream character
to go out like this. Maybe Scream 5 will feature
Stu and Angelina as the Ghostface killers.
Personally, I don’t think there’s a ton
of evidence to suggest she’s alive, though
it is definitely a small possibility. But
I am of the belief that she was the Roman’s
accomplice, and there’s a ton of evidence
to support that. Let me know your thoughts
on Angelina in the comments.
Scream 3 was marketed as the last Scream.
The final act. The very end. So join me next
time on Things You Missed as I cover Scre4m.
Also known as Scream 4.
Scre4m welcomed us back to Woodsboro High
School, it doesn’t look exactly the same,
but this could technically be a different
entrance, and this could just be a different
part of the building. But one aspect that
is definitely a new addition, which you might
have missed, is this bust, dedicated to the
late Principal Arthur Himbry, who was one
of the victims in Scream 1.
Here’s a little bit of a better look from
a behind the scenes photo.
For other references you might not have noticed,
like the movie props featured in the background
of Stab-a-thon, stick around to the end of
this video.
This video is sponsored by NordVPN
♪ Metal Music ♪
Welcome to Things You Missed. I am ‘Don’t
Look At My Tits I Have A Mind Morris,’ and
if you remembered that reference, it probably
hasn’t been long since you last watched
Scre4m. And I actually think this is one of
the most warranted examples putting a number
in the title in place of a letter. In a movie
like Se7en, or Thir13n Ghosts, there’s no
real reason for it other than style. But since
this movie serves as a satire of horror movie
remakes, most of which have the same title
as the original, inserting the number 4 allows
you to read it as just Scream, while still
differentiating that this is the fourth movie.
Which makes it all the more disappointing
that they didn’t follow suit with Scream
(2022) by calling it 5cream. Let’s get in
to the Things You Missed.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Being a remake, this one opens exactly the
same way the original did, with a teen girl
receiving a phone call. Sherrie and Trudie
are trying to pick a movie, and we see the
blue screen on the TV, something I talked
about when I covered the original Scream,
which represents the idea that a movie is
about to begin, not only for us, the audience,
but also the characters, who are somewhat
aware that they are living through a movie.
However, this is the first movie to take place
well after the others, it’s set in 2010,
so the new horror reference points for the
young characters are noughties horror like
Saw and Final Destination. Saw in particular
seems to have the biggest influence on Scream 4.
It’s the movie that Sherrie chooses for
movie night, and the color grade takes after
the Saw look. For example, look at the first
outdoor scene, and how the bloom resembles
the look of the Public Execution Trap from
Saw 7. Or for a better idea of exactly how
the look of this movie differs from the previous
ones, try comparing the Stab footage from
Scream 2 to that of the fourth movie.
There are also a few scenes that seem to have
Saw’s imprint on them. Olivia encounters
her masked attacker hiding in her closet,
just like Adam from Saw. Rebecca is ambushed
in an empty parking garage, just like Dr.
Gordon from Saw. One of the side characters
is Robbie Mercer, who is played by Erik Knudsen;
he was Daniel Matthews in Saw 2, and both
of them know a lot about cameras. Stab is
now a seven movie series, just like Saw was
at the time. Stab-a-thon is held in an abandoned
barn. This was well before Jigsaw, the Saw
movie set in an abandoned barn, but Gale’s
coming across this creepy pig head next to
these rusty gears still looks like something
right out of the original Saw saga, or as
some of you suggested on my Saw videos, the
Saw-ga.
The opening of Scre4m also serves as a mission
statement about what we should expect for
this movie. And that is, to expect the unexpected.
– [Charlie] The unexpected is the new cliche.
Modern audiences get savvy to the rules of
the originals. So the reverse has become the
new standard.
– The intro does this with it’s false
openings. First we see two girls get killed;
turns out that’s just Stab 6. Then we get
some meta-cinema commentary from our new characters…
–[Rachel] It’s all so predictable, there’s no
element of surprise, you can see everything
coming! (stab)
– …but that just turns out to be Stab
7. So we’re seeing first hand how filmmakers
are now actively trying to do what the audience
doesn’t expect in the decade since Stab 3.
And this, of course, also applies to our
movie, Scream 4. Scre4m.
So after those two false intros, we meet our
real intro characters, Marnie Cooper and Jenny
Randall. Marnie does share a last name with
Cici Cooper from Scream 2, but they probably
aren’t related -- despite their shared eye
and hair color. I’m actually more interested
in her first name, Marnie, because it brings
to mind the 1964 Alfred Hitchcock film. Being
one of the most important figures in the horror
genre, Hitchcock has already been the subject
of several homages in the Scream franchise,
like Billy Loomis sharing a name with Sam
Loomis from Psycho, the shower shot from Psycho
being in Stab, and one of the actresses in
Scream 3 incorrectly identifying it as a reference
to Vertigo, among others.
In the classroom where Cinema Club is held,
you can spot a Vertigo poster. On the chalkboard,
there’s a lesson about the plot structure
of Hitchcock’s Rear Window, and Kirby’s
room has a Rear Window poster as well. Marnie
may not be the only Hitchcock namesake. Sidney
has a publicist named Rebecca, which could
be an homage to Hitchcock’s 1940 film Rebecca,
and the police officer, Perkins, is actually
named Anthony Perkins, we hear his partner
call him that.
–[Det Hoss] Anthony! Perkins!
– Anthony Perkins is the actor who
played Norman Bates in Psycho. The rest of
the intro sequence features a lot of fun homages
to the Scream franchise, like Ghostface trying
to tell Jenny to think of him as her director.
– [Caller] You’re in my movie. You’ve
got a fun part! So don't blow it.
– The last villain literally was the
director of Stab 3. Marnie is sent crashing
through the glass door a la Steve Orth from
Scream.
– [Caller] But you? You’re the dumb blond
with the big tits. We’ll have some fun with
you before you die.
– And just like Sidney predicted in the
first Scream, she makes the mistake of running
up the stairs rather than out the door. She
ends up going to the attic, like Sidney did
while trying to escape Ghostface at Stu’s
house, and then eventually to the garage,
where her escape is foiled by the garage door,
just like Tatum in Scream.
Dewey is woken up by his ringtone.
(80s techno)
The song is Axel F, from the soundtrack of
Beverly Hills Cop. And Dewey is also a cop
again, he’s not the Sheriff of Woodsboro.
Also of note, this song has been remade many
times, by the likes of TechnoCop, Clock, and
yes… Crazy Frog.
–[Crazy Frog] Ding. Ding.
– Soon we meet the next generation
of Woodsboro High School students. It seems
that Kirby knows who the killer is without
actually knowing who the killer is.
–[Kirby] Before you get in the car, you have to
promise not to kill me.
– There’s a similar foreshadowing moment
like this later when Officer Hoss is doing
a crossword puzzle and asks Perkins for a
four letter word for courage.
– [Perkins] Uhh… Guts.
– It would not be long after that when Olivia’s
guts would be ripped out by Ghostface. The
event is also foreshadowed by these chinese
take-out boxes that have a red splatter design.
But before we get there, we would check in
on the current state of Gale Riley, whose
office plays host to a few more Things You
Missed.
(Thunder)
Each new character in the fourth installment
of Scream is a spiritual successor to one
of the characters from the original Scream.
Which is why it’s a satire of horror movie remakes.
Like a remake you have new actors
playing old roles. Jill is the new Sidney
Prescott, a high school student thrust into
danger due to the attack of her family member.
Trevor is Billy Loomis, the boyfriend who
becomes a major suspect. Kirby is Randy Meeks,
the biggest horror film buff of the friend
group and walking knowledge database. Olivia
is Tatum Riley, the attractive popular girl
who dies way too early. Charlie is Stu Macher,
the easily peer pressured friend. Robbie Mercer
is Kenny, the camera guy. And Rebecca is Gale
Weathers, the media. She even makes the comparison
between Dewey and Barney Fife, just like Gale
did back in Scream 2.
– [Dewey] Page 32. Deputy Dewey filled the
room with his Barney Fife-ish presence.
– [Rebecca] Just wait, Barney Fife, I’m
running an event here.
– Speaking of Gale, she’s now writing
a work of fiction, after penning the book
trilogy that became the basis for the Stab
movies, and we can see them right here: The
Woodsboro Murders, College Terror and Hollywood
Horror. It seems that she also wrote other
stories about a Ghostface killer because there’s
this additional book, Ghostface Returns, which
we get a better look at later in Jill’s
room. This is probably the basis of the fictional
Stab movies 4 through 7.
After news that the killings have started
again breaks, we see the Woodsboro police
station, and if you pause, you can see the
KQIS 6 van whirring by in the foreground.
This is the same station that Gale worked
for back in Scream 1, where the van was parked
outside during Stu Macher’s party. We also
see the channel 6 microphone appear a couple
times throughout the movie.
Rebecca is celebrating the news of the two
girls being butchered, and she calls it a
payday. The media sensationalizing the crimes
has been a theme that has run through each
of the Scream movies so far. In the first
and second films it’s the TV news media,
in the third it’s the Hollywood film industry
and now we’re seeing it happen in publishing.
There would also be another angle to this
present in Scream 4: social media. Robbie
gets involved as essentially what we would
now call the IRL streamer, and the killers
are recording all their kills, which Jill
plans to use to help frame Trevor and Charlie
and anticipates that the footage will go viral
and garner her more attention. However, she
fails, so this part never pans out.
Later in the movie, Rebecca tries to convince
Sidney to sign a new book deal.
–[Rebecca] You’re a victim. For life. So embrace
it!
– And this is another aspect of the social
commentary about the media. Rebecca doesn't
understand the point of Sidney's book, it's
about her journey to no longer be the victim.
Jill, on the other hand, is on a journey to
become the victim.
–[Jill] How do you think people become famous
anymore? You don’t have to achieve anything.
You just gotta have f*cked up sh*t happen
to you.
– She's an extreme example of someone with
what we would now call victim mentality. Like
the original Scream's social commentary about
sensationalizing violence in the news, and
Scream 3's commentary about inappropriate
relations in Hollywood, Scre4m's take on victim
mentality has only become more relevant over
the years as more and more people try to invent
a scenario where they are perceived as having
been wronged, with the intention of going
viral.
The "my experience with ____" trope on social
media has become as cliche as the slasher
movies that Randy idolized in Scream.
–[sunhatkid] He had me unfollow all of them, which
to me was really weird, and I didn’t like it.
– But anyway, when Rebecca meets Gale, Gale
tells her that she is Gale Riley now; she’s
been married to Dewey for 10 years, to which
Rebecca is surprised.
– It always seemed like more of a movie
romance than a real one because it was a movie.
And in real life you two would never be…
ooh!
– In my Scream 3 video, I mentioned that
Dewey and Gale’s marriage was one of the
many plot elements inspired by real life,
because David Arquette and Courtney Cox actually
got married. Now they had actually been married
10 years and, like in the movie, their relationship
was in trouble. They separated in real life
in 2010, the same year this movie is set.
The trouble in the on-screen marriage is exemplified
that evening at the house, in a line that
also serves as another callback to that Dewey
and Gale scene from Scream 2. This time instead
of Dewey quoting a specific page from Gale’s
book, he’s quoting Sidney’s book in regards
to his marriage.
–[Dewey] Just when you think things can’t get
any worse, sometimes they don’t. Sometimes
they get better. Out of Darkness by Sidney
Prescott, page 220.
– Later in the evening, after Ghostface
comes for Olivia, Sidney tries to get into
The Morris Household to save her, and she
does so by throwing a potted plant through
the window.
Sidney has always been seen as the slasher
successor to Laurie Strode from Halloween,
with her story even running parallel to Laurie’s
in Scream 1, and now we’ve got her throwing
a potted plant at a house, like Laurie in
Halloween.
As always, the movie is packed with Halloween
references. When Sidney makes a guest appearance
at the Cinema Club, Robbie hypes up her presence
by comparing her to the actresses who starred
in Halloween and The Exorcist.
– [Robbie] Beyond Jamie Lee Curtis, forget
Linda Blair, this is the ultimate.
– Which is also its own kind of joke because
they both appear in Scream 1. The cinema club
holds their party, Stab-a-thon, at an abandoned
farm house, much like the party in Halloween 5.
But if you look closer, there’s a for
sale sign outside the farm that says Roberts
Reality. Roberts refers to Sidney’s mom’s
side of the family. Her mother was Maureen
Roberts before getting married, and Sidney’s
aunt is Kate Roberts. She is the realtor that
this sign is referring to. Earlier drafts
of the script make mention of her profession.
Kate takes Sidney in while she’s back in
Woodsboro. We can assume that Sidney’s dad
moved away or died, because he’s not in
the movie. So Sidney is staying with a realtor,
who happens to be selling the location of
“Stab-a-thon”.
And this is another similarity she has to
Laurie Strode, who, after losing her parents
is taken in by the Strode family, and her
new adoptive father is a realtor who is selling
a house, the Myers House, which was the location
of more of a literal Stab-a-thon.
With Sidney being part of the older generation
now, she takes responsibility for the kids’
safety. Towards the end, she instructs Jill
to hide under a bed and then makes it look
as if she’s helped her escape off the balcony.
This is very similar to Laurie’s strategy
in Halloween.
Of course, there’s one line where Sid is
made out to look more less like Laurie and
more like her brother…
–[Jill] You just won’t die will you? Who are
you? Michael f*cking Myers?
– The last Halloween reference I want to
bring up is this poster seen in the classroom
where Cinema Club is held. If you’ve seen
Rob Zombie’s Halloween 2, you know it is
not a remake of Halloween 2. Rob Zombie’s
Halloween 1 is a remake of the original Halloween,
however Rob Zombie’s Halloween 2 goes off
in it’s own… strange direction.
I’m guessing this was likely a hint about
what the plans were for the Scream franchise.
In January 2010, screenwriter Kevin Williamson,
who had returned after an absence in Scream 3
stated that he was contracted to make Scream
4 and Scream 5. However, the fourth movie
underperformed at the box office, director
Wes Craven got brain cancer, and the fifth
installment had to be put on the shelf. Save
that one for a rainy decade.
But as long as we’re talking about the meta
of Scre4m, I’ve also gotta mention what
is perhaps the most meta thing in the whole
franchise.
♪ Suspenseful Music ♪
Remember that cop character, Anthony Perkins?
Well not only is he named after a Psycho actor,
but he also appeared in Scary Movie 3. Scary
Movie is a parody of Scream and Scream is
a satire of the horror genre.
If you’ve kept up with my Scream Things
You Missed series, you already know that the
first Scream contained many references to
slasher movies, including Wes Craven’s own
work. So Scream 4 focuses on movies that were
remade. The new version of the video store
scene is the Cinema Club scene where we see
a whole bunch of movie posters, like this
one: The Hills Have Eyes. This checks both
boxes, it was directed by Wes Craven and it
received a remake in 2006.
If you’re really paying attention you’ll
also notice the poster for The People Under
The Stairs,
a 1991 Wes Craven production. Before his death,
Craven planned to remake this, but never quite
got around to it.
There’s also a poster for George Romero’s
Dawn of the Dead. It was remade in 2004. The
Thing is a remake of The Thing From Another
World from 1951. You may notice the poster
on the left is not a horror movie, it’s
a film called Zack and Miri Make a Porno.
This is actually a continuation of a series
of easter eggs between Wes Craven and Kevin
Smith. I talked about this in greater detail
in my Scream 3 episode, but the two directors
have been exchanging cameos and easter eggs
in their movies since the original Scream.
If you look around the classroom, you’ll
also see that the Cinema Club are big fans
of the Stab franchise. You can see the Stab
poster right here, and the Stab 3 poster back
in the corner. An interesting note here is
the tagline for Stab 3 is “Hollywood Horror”.
Which means this is not the same movie we
saw being shot in Scream 3, whose tagline
was “Return To Woodsboro.” It seems that
since all the cast was killed, the studio
decided to make Stab 3 about that, rather
than trying to recast for Return To Woodsboro.
Little did they know, the story would return
to Woodsboro all on its own.
Behind this shelf is the Stab 5 poster, and
the Stab 6 poster. But that’s really only
just the beginning of the display of their
Stab fandom. We see much more that night at
Stab-a-thon where there are a lot of background
details you may have missed.
Here’s a girl dressed as Casey Becker, posing
with a decoration of the “gutted” Casey
Becker, which you can see more of behind the
crowd right here. Another display shows Tatum
Riley hanging out of the garage flap. Many
of the attendees are wearing costumes of Scream
and Stab characters. Something that is very
accurate if you’ve ever been to a screening.
These two guys in the audience are both dressed
as Dewey, and one of them even has a mustache
hat. There’s another Casey Becker on the
left. A lot of the kids have Woodsboro High
letterman jackets, like Casey’s boyfriend
Steve Orth, but then again, those are also
their actual high school jackets, so I won’t
count that one. But I will count this couple
dressed as Gale and Dewey, Gale in her green
news dress and Dewey in his uniform.
– [Gale] This party is all about the Stab
movies, come on! How meta can you get?
– [Dewey] How what-a can you get?
– [Gale] I don’t know, I heard him say it.
– Gale places cameras around the party much
like she did in Scream, so that she can watch
from her vehicle. In fact, one of the cameras
is right beneath the movie screen, just as
the surveillance camera in Scream was placed
under Stu’s television.
Now you’re probably wondering: are there
differences between the version of Stab we
saw in Scream 2 and what we see in Scream
4? So I cut both films apart and lined them
both up, and the answer is: yes there are
a lot of differences. Enough to make a whole
video about it, which I plan on doing. But
for this video, I’m only gonna talk about
the ones that are interesting.
In Scream 4 we see this card at the beginning:
A Robert Rodriguez Film. This sort-of qualifies
as a crew reference easter egg, because Robert
Rodriguez was brought in to film the Stab
footage for Scream 2.
After lining up all the cut points, there’s
an interesting synchronization that occurs.
Which is that Gale gets stabbed at the same
time as Casey in Stab, which in Scream 2,
occurred at the same time Maureen was stabbed
inside the movie theater. Just thought that
was kind of cool.
Before being attacked, Gale holds her camera
by her waist, looking behind her, unintentionally
recreating the moment from Scream where the
characters in the news van see Ghostface sneaking
up behind Randy.
–[Kenny] Behind you kid!
–[Sidney] Randy!
– This time it’s Dewey, concerned about
Gale.
–[Dewey] Gale! Gale behind you!
– This is more than just a nostalgic callback
though, it also sets up a scene later where
Robbie puts his headset on backwards. We’re
expecting Ghostface to appear behind him,
so it’s more of a surprise when the killer
ends up being right in front of him, just
another example of this movie’s mission
to do the unexpected.
That also includes the film’s ending. We
are led to believe that it will end at the
party, just like the original, but…
–[Charlie] This is what the reboots do, they one-up
the original ending.
–[Kirby] The Woodsboro Murders ended at a party.
So in the remake…
–[Charlie] The party’s the false ending. New rules.
– However, this also ends up being a false
ending, the true ending takes place at the
hospital. Just as there were two false openings,
there are also two false endings. This is
also something that happens in the Halloween
remake. The original ends at the Doyle house,
but the remake continues on and ends at the
Myers house. There are probably other examples
of remakes in the 2000s doing this though.
So in this case, we have the quote unquote
remake continuing on past the original. Whereas,
in the 90s, if you wanted to continue past
the original, you had to watch Scream 2, which
contains a scene of a character named Cici
watching the movie Nosferatu, and getting
killed shortly after. For this reason, I find
it fitting that Kirby’s room displays a
Nosferatu poster, but who knows if there was
any actual meaning behind this choice, it’s
kind of a stretch on my part to make that
connection.
However, I am convinced that the wardrobe
choices were definitely done for a reason.
I talked before about how each character in
Scre4m represents one of the characters from
Scream. However, after the reveal of the killers,
all of those roles are reassigned. Jill is
now Billy, the mastermind behind the murders.
Charlie is still Stu, the accomplice hoping
to vent his romantic frustrations with a knife.
Trevor is now Neil Prescott, the tied up victim
who is going to be framed.
So it’s no mistake that Jill is wearing
a blue plaid shirt, just like what Billy wore
at the party, and Trevor is wearing this exact
outfit that Neil was captured in back in 1996.
Other callbacks include Sidney escaping off
the roof, Charlie being tied to a chair like
Steve Orth, Kirby being quizzed on horror
movies like Casey Becker, and of course, this
iconic line.
–[Jill] Hello Sidney. Surprised?
–[Mickey] Surprise, Sidney.
–[Stu] Surprise, Sidney.
– I imagine she’s getting tired of hearing
that. In my personal opinion, Scre4m was one
of the more satisfying surprises though, which
makes all the clues about the killers’ identities
all the more impressive.
♪ Upbeat Music ♪
Upon rewatching the movie, I noticed that
while Jill and Charlie pretend they aren’t
particularly close, they do sit next to each
other in class, and Jill is the only one not
to take out her phone when everyone is getting
alerts about Jenny and Marnie, though I’m
not sure why she doesn’t at least pretend
to be interested.
On a somewhat related note, fellow Zac and
fellow horror creator Zack Cherry pointed
out in his video that Sidney doesn’t appear
to have a cell phone in this movie. She receives
calls on Jill’s cell and on the Roberts’
landline, and after arriving at Kirby’s
she borrows Jill’s phone to place an outgoing
call to Dewey to plea for help.
This is probably because Sidney is tired of
all the prank calls and doesn’t want to
give any future copycat killers a means of
contacting her, it’s a nice touch. Mr. Cherry
also attributes a lot of the kills to Charlie,
which many were surprised by, but I personally
think it kind of makes sense. Jill would have
wanted to set it up that way because of the
fact that they’re recording all of the kills
and the fact that she’s secretly planning
to frame Charlie as the one of the killers
alongside Trevor.
It stands to reason that the police would
probably study these videos, and take note
of the killer’s height and broad shoulders.
Charlie might also be the most forceful Ghostface
we’ve seen. Check this out.
(woman wimpering)
When I analyzed Scream 1, I mentioned that
the poster in Stu’s room matched a poster
displayed in the video store, and that this
linked his character to the movie obsessed
killer. A similar tactic is used here. Jill’s
room is filled with clues. This Farewell Republic
poster and this… uhh, I don’t know, reverse
Griffon?... are both posters seen hanging
in the Cinema Club.
I will mention the possibility that there
is actually no meaning behind that. They could
have just reused posters and hoped nobody
would notice. Because this War of The Worlds
poster in Jill’s room also shows up in her
English class. I can’t think of any reason
they’d want to link Jill to her English
classroom. So it’s very possible that the
art department just ran out of posters and
I’m just looking for things that aren’t
there.
But at the very least, we can conclude that
Jill is more interested in horror movies and
serial killers than she likes to let on, from
her American Werewolf in London poster, to
her Edgar Allan Poe-ster, to her Gale Weathers
books, books on psychology and serial killers
and even her Fall Out Boy poster; this particular
one is the cover for their single I Don’t
Care, whose chorus matches her MO for the
movie. “I. Don’t. Care what you think.
As long as it’s about me.”
This might be more happenstance, but this
is also off their album Folie a Deux, which
is French for madness in pairs, a term that
could probably be used to describe each pair
of Ghostface killers. I love this album, and
I’d love to talk more about it, but this
is not a music analysis channel, so let’s
get back to Scre4m.
After Olivia is killed, Charlie comes out
of the dark to attack Sidney and Jill, and
Jill receives a cut on her forearm, the same
spot Derek got cut in Scream 2.
–[Medic] No struggle? He just cut you and ran away?
You’re lucky he didn’t kill you.
–[Dewey] Yeah, it’s awfully convenient.
–[Derek] Say what?
–[Dewey] Nothing,
it’s just a shame he got away so easily.
–[Derek] It’s just a shame you got there too
late!
– Of course, Derek ended up not being guilty,
so Dewey would probably want to avoid making
any similar accusation about Jill.
When Sidney speaks to Jill the following night,
she has what she thinks is a bonding moment
with her cousin.
– [Sidney] You know when people say, ‘I
know how you feel’, but they’re really
just saying that because they have no freaking
idea how you feel? I know how you feel.
– I love that line, because in reality,
Sidney has no idea how Jill feels because
she doesn’t suspect her of being the killer.
It’s like the sticker on the door of the
Cinema Club says: Not your usual suspects.
Jill claims she could never handle the attention
of being the surviving victim, when in fact,
that’s exactly what she wants, even if her
15 minutes of fame really is only 15 minutes.
And finally, at Kirby’s afterparty, Trevor
shows up unexpectedly, and just walks right
in because the door is unlocked.
– [Trevor] By the way Kirby, with everything
that’s going on right now, you probably shouldn’t leave that unlocked.
– [Charlie] Sorry.
Charlie is not worried about locking the door
because he knows there’s no threat. He and
Jill are both in the room already.
Scre4m would be the final legacy of director Wes Craven, but his creation would live on
without him after yet another 11 year gap
with Scream (2022).
Most Scream fans already know about how Scream
(2022) paid tribute to Wes Craven, the director
of Screams 1-4, by naming a character after
him, having a house party dedicated to that
character after his death, and repeating the
words: “For Wes”, as the first thing we
see in the end credits. What you might not
have noticed was the hidden meaning behind
Wes’s phone number. The “707” is just
the area code for the part of Northern California
where Woodsboro would be located, and all
the Woodsboro characters have this area code,
but “1939” refers to the year Wes Craven
was born.
We actually see Craven’s birthday come up
again later during the YouTube video about
Stab (2021). The channel’s subscriber count
is 821,939, which could be read as 8/2/1939.
Under the American date format of month, day,
year, this represents August 2, 1939, the
day Wes Craven was born.
This page contains a lot of other easter eggs,
including other hidden dates in the numbers.
To learn about many classic cameos, secrets
on tattoos and meanings behind names on cell
phones, stick around to the end of this video.
♪ Metal Music ♪
Welcome to Things You Missed. When I heard
there was going to be a new Scream movie,
I was hoping that the franchise would come
back to tackle the phenomenon of requels,
like Halloween (2018), Jurassic World and
Candyman (2021). Then, I started watching
Scream (2022) and realized, oh yeah, Scre4m
already was a requel. Also, I generally don’t
really like requels.
But what I do like about them though, is that
they’re basically easter nests. What do
I mean by that? A nest is somewhere you might
find a lot of eggs. In this case easter eggs,
as in the hidden secrets found in contemporary
media. One of my favorite things to analyze
on Things You Missed. So let’s get in to
the Things You Missed.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Each entry in the Scream franchise serves
as a satire of the horror genre and sometimes
of media franchises as a whole. As you are
very aware of if you’ve seen my previous
videos on Scream, Scream 2, Scream 3 and Scre4m,
there are a few franchises that they like
to use as a blueprint of sorts. First there’s
Halloween, the movie shown in the first Scream,
which served as an example of horror movie
rules. Then there’s Star Wars, which was
most heavily discussed in Scream 3 when the
characters were trying to figure out the rules
for trilogies. Finally there’s Scream, which
also exists in-universe where it’s known
as the Stab franchise.
So many things that happen in Scream (2022),
from bigger plot points to little moments,
are callbacks to things that have happened
in the Scream franchise, which is also fitting
for a requel, because these movies often share
the same concept of: “it’s happening again.”
So for the third time in franchise history,
it starts with a phone ringing, then a female
picking it up and speaking to an anonymous
caller, then she starts playing with a knife
block, then she gets attacked by Ghostface,
and then she kicks her attacker in an attempt
to escape.
Then in a parallel to Scream 1, a group of
friends discusses the attack the next day
while sitting outside of Woodsboro High School
while eating grapes. We find out boyfriend
and girlfriend Chad and Liv aren’t sleeping
together, like Sidney and Billy in Scream;
an announcement from the high school principal
cancels classes, just like in Scream. But
did you notice who the new principal was?
– [Principal] Attention, Panthers. A reminder
that all
classes and school activities are canceled
tomorrow due to public safety concerns.
– According to executive producer
Chad Villela,
in this interview with Bloody Disgusting,
that was a voice cameo from Drew Barrymore,
who is known for playing Casey Becker in the
original Scream. There are many other voice
cameos present in the movie. Most of them
can be heard during Amber’s party. The first
comes from Matthew Lillard, who played Stu
in Scream.
–[Party Guy] Hey Freeman, cool house!
– Fitting, considering that this is
Stu’s
old house. Several cameo voices overlap when
the guests make a toast to the character Wes.
– [Chad] Hey. To Wes!
– [crowd] To Wes!
– The article states that many people who
knew
Wes Craven contributed voices for this line,
including 3 Scream actors: Henry Winkler,
who played Principal Himbry, Adam Brody, who
played Officer Hoss in Scre4m and Hayden Panettiere,
who played Kirby.
Co-director Tyler Gillett added that Jamie
Kennedy, who played Randy in the original
Scream trilogy, contributed this line:
–[Jamie] Somebody’s goofy ass dad is kicking
us out.
– …which he actually says right while
his
character is delivering his lines in Stab,
which is playing on the TV, where we can see
another cameo. Co-director Matt Bettinelli-Olpin
revealed that he plays the on-screen Michael
Myers in the movie-within-the-movie-within-the-movie.
Maybe we should stop calling it Scream and
start calling it Shrek because this thing
has got layers. Speaking of Halloween, there’s
also a reference to its director.
– [Sam] My name is Samantha Carpenter.
– This is an homage to Halloween director
John
Carpenter. Or possibly Wes Carpenter.
– [Tatum] Don't go there Sid, you're starting
to sound like some Wes Carpenter flick or
something.
– The new directors for Scream (2022) went
a
little crazy with references to Wes Craven’s
body of work, starting with Sidney Prescott’s
address.
– [Tara] Sidney Prescott! It’s Sidney
Prescott and she lived on Elm.
Although it was mentioned in the original
script, I don’t think that Sid’s street
address was ever brought up in the first movie.
But Elm is a reference to Elm Street, from
Wes Craven’s famous franchise, A Nightmare
on Elm Street. We actually see the Elm Street
intersection later when Sam and Richie roll
into town.
Then, when we’re reintroduced to Dewey,
you can see the list of his cell phone contacts
if you pause at the right moment. One of his
contacts is “Kristy” which is probably
a reference to Kristy Parker from A Nightmare
on Elm St 3 and 4. Kristy is played by Patricia
Arquette, the real life sister of Dewey's
actor: David Arquette.
Also of note in Dewey’s list of contacts
is B Miska. Which is a nod to Brad Miska,
the owner of horror movie news website Bloody
Disgusting, which may explain why they have
all these exclusive interviews with the directors
and producers, which I keep referencing. During
the YouTube scene later on, the related videos
panel also suggests an upload from the Bloody
Disgusting channel; another exclusive interview,
but we’ll get to that later.
Under B Miska, keeping up with the theme of
internet horror personalities is Mr. Morris.
That’s me, Zac Morris. You might be thinking,
no it’s just the father of Olivia Morris
from Scre4m. But no. She doesn’t have a
father.
– [Kirby] Your mom home?
– [Olivia] She’s at her boyfriend’s.
– So it must be talking about me. If Dead
Meat
gets to be in it, I get to be in it too, damnit!
Another one of Dewey’s contacts is Judy,
which is probably just Judy Hicks, his old
deputy at the police station. I was thinking
it’s kind of a shame that he never got with
her after he split up with Gale, but who knows,
maybe he did. Actually, now that I think about
it, she must have already had a kid by the
time she was hitting on Dewey in Scre4m so…
that’s weird.
We actually see her list of contacts too,
and you can spot more Wes Craven related homages.
Tina G represents Tina Gray from the original
Nightmare on Elm Street. Leroy is a character
from Craven’s 1991 film, The People Under
The Stairs. Nancy T, of course, is Nancy Thompson,
the main girl from A Nightmare on Elm Street.
B Adams is Brandon Adams, the actor who played
Fool in The People Under The Stairs.
Under her son, there are three deputies listed.
Deputy Vinson and Deputy Farney are actual
characters in the movie. Deputy Keith is not,
I’m guessing this is a crew reference easter
egg, because the movie’s production designer
is named Chad Keith.
For all the Wes Craven related easter eggs,
it seems like there’s only one easter egg
related to Kevin Williamson, the screenwriter
of Screams 1, 2 and 4. It comes when Tara
is in the hospital watching an episode of
Dawson’s Creek. This is Season 1 Episode
11: The Scare, which was written by Williamson,
and the episode itself is kind of spoof of
the original Scream. Like I said: there are
a lot of layers to this.
We’re not done with the Wes Craven easter
eggs though. I’ll be continuing to analyze
those, and Richie’s big slip up, that would
have given him away as the killer if only
his girlfriend had noticed.
(impact)
♪ Dreadful Music ♪
Throughout the movie, we see a couple of memorials
to past characters. Dewey has a box dedicated
to his sister, Tatum; and Martha has a home
theater dedicated to her brother, Randy. On
the mantle there’s also a photo of a movie
theater marquee with three movies playing:
A Nightmare on Elm Street, The Hills Have
Eyes and Last House on the Left -- all Wes
Craven directed films.
Sam Carpenter is essentially the new Sidney
Prescott in this movie. Much like Sidney’s
father in the original, we learn Sam’s mom
is out of town. Both of their mothers are
cheaters, and both characters have some psychological
issues caused by Billy Loomis -- Sidney because
Billy killed her mother, and Sam because Billy
is her real father. Throughout the series
I’ve discussed how Sidney shares similarities
with Halloween’s protagonist Laurie Strode.
Sam takes after her as well. Laurie was a
babysitter in the original Halloween, and
it turns out Sam has some experience in childcare
as well.
– [Sam] There are Chad and Mindy, the twins.
And
Wes. I used to babysit them all.
– The first victim to die this time around
is
Vince, who we eventually learn to be Stu Macher’s
nephew. In a requel, everyone has to have
some dumb reason to be related to legacy characters.
There’s actually a little clue about this
in the opening scene, where Tara looks up
the cast of the original Stab on her phone.
There’s a new addition here, a cast member
who wasn’t specified back in Scream 2, and
that is Vince Vaughn playing the role of Stu
Macher. So the names Vince and Stu are kind
of linked from the beginning.
There’s also a detail on the hood of Vince’s
car. Not only a movie detail, but like an
actual car detail. The words: Six Pack are
written there, perhaps a hint that we’ll
be seeing a sixth movie. Also this guy parked
in front of him is parked in front of a fire
hydrant. Come on man, the cops are right there.
Vince also has a Jason tattoo. This is probably
a red herring to make the audience think he
might be the killer, considering the line
Richie had earlier.
–[Richie] And I gotta make sure we don’t get sliced
up by some lunatic who saw Friday the 13th
and thought, ‘you know what? That Jason
guy, he’s got some pretty solid ideas.’
– Of course, Vince ends up being a
victim, not
a killer. During his death scene, we hear
the song Red Right Hand, which appeared in
every Scream movie besides Scre4m, so it’s
good to see it back on rotation here. Ghostface
actually takes out Vince with his own switchblade,
not the usual Ghostface knife. I’m guessing
this is just another red herring though, to
make it look like Vince was somehow connected.
Finally after like 35 minutes, we see Sidney
Prescott. She’s a runner now, which seems
like a reasonable hobby after a lifetime of
being chased by psychopaths, and she finally
owns a cell phone. She never had one in Scre4m,
but seeing as how that didn’t prevent her
from being targeted by the next Ghostface,
she probably decided to just cave in and get
one.
Dewey mentions that she’s married to someone
named Mark. There is a Mark in the Scream
franchise, that is, Detective Mark Kincaid,
the cop from Scream 3 who weirdly came back
to her house and watched movies with the trio
at the end. One of the Bloody Disgusting articles
I mentioned earlier addresses this; the executive
producer confirms that Sidney’s husband
is indeed Mark Kincaid. I can’t say this
fully makes sense to me, because where was
he in Scre4m and where is he now? And why
is Sidney’s name still Sidney Prescott?
I’m guessing she still wanted to take advantage
of the notoriety of her name for her career
as an author.
The original Scream featured a scene known
as the video store scene, where Randy speculates
on who the killer might be. Every subsequent
sequel so far has had its own version of the
video
store scene. This time, it’s the Randy Meeks
Memorial Theater scene, and Mindy, the new
Randy, fills the gang in on her ideas about
who might be guilty.
At one point during this scene, Dewey refers
to Stu Macher as “A real Looney Tune.”
This may be a reference to the fact that Stu
was in the 2003 movie: Looney Tunes: Back
in Action, where he plays himself, Matthew
Lillard arguing, with Shaggy (also voiced
by Lillard) about the quality of his performance
in Scooby-Doo: The Movie; a scene probably
meta enough to be in a Scream movie, if we’re
being honest.
In the background, there’s a Vertigo poster.
This is now the third Scream movie in a row
to reference Vertigo, starting with Sarah’s
line in Scream 3, and this poster in Scre4m.
Vertigo is directed by Alfred Hitchcock, who
borderline invented the slasher genre with
his movie: Psycho. Psycho has been referenced
in every Scream movie, and that continues
here, with this poster, Amber imitating the
Psycho soundtrack as she gestures her knife…
–[Amber] Ee, ee, ee!
– …One of the Ghostface killers even directly
cites the movie this time around.
– [Killer] Ever seen the movie Psycho?
– And then we cut directly to this shot,
where
Wes is taking a shower. It’s the same camera
angle used in the shower scene from Psycho
and subsequently, the shower scene from Stab
in the second Scream.
The next character to die is Wes. As I mentioned,
he gets out of the shower and explores around
downstairs. In the kitchen there’s a note
from his mom. “Wes, Lemon squares in the
fridge. ♥ Mom”.
This is a callback to Judy’s famous lemon
squares, which she made for Dewey in Scre4m.
– [Judy] Sheriff, you’re not cheatin’
on your wife if
you eat my lemon square.
– The ones that Gale found disgusting.
– [Gale] Your lemon squares taste like ***.
Speaking
of whom, she returns to the story by stepping
out of this KQIS 6 news van. It’s the same
station that Gale worked for in Scream, but
ever since then, she’s worked other jobs
such as uptodate, 60 Minutes II, Total Entertainment,
and she even went rogue for a while. Seeing
her back at her original station is exactly
the choice you’d expect from a requel looking
not to upset the status quo.
At this point, Dewey and Gale are divorced,
an event we already saw brewing in Scre4m,
but it sounds like their divorce went exactly
like their break-up in between Scream 2 and
Scream 3: Gale gets an important job opportunity
in a big city and the two can’t make it
work long distance. Dewey belongs in Woodsboro,
Gale belongs in a big city reporter job. Once
again, history seems to be repeating itself
with these two.
Despite Gale being back in her old job, the
underlying theme about the media and its effect
on real world violence is not as present in
the
new Scream like it was in the first four movies.
We do get a little bit of discourse about
the entertainment news industry at the end,
where Richie seems to imply he was driven
to the brink partly by the media blaming the
fans for the poor reception of the new Stab
movie, but I see that as just one aspect of
a bigger conversation around this idea of
toxic fandom.
So what is toxic fandom? Is it real? Is it
a problem? Should we be worried about it?
The most agreed upon definition reads: When
a person believes they have the only correct
way of appreciating certain content. They
will attack other fans that disagree with
them even if they are discussing a topic the
toxic fan knows little about or has only heard
from second-hand sources.
I will add that it seems that “toxic fandom”
has also become a buzzword used by journalists
or salty creators to try to get clicks and
sway a narrative. For example, let’s say
a new movie from a popular franchise comes
out and it’s bad. Those involved might soon
be crying about “toxic fandom” to try
to make all criticisms look invalid. I’m
sure there are fans in those cases who dislike
that new movie merely because it does not
fit their belief about what that franchise
should be like, but that does not make the
entire fandom toxic, and it shouldn’t invalidate
good criticisms based on the quality of the
work.
So is it a problem, should we be worried about
it? At the end of the day, it’s all online
discourse. There’s no reason to take it
that seriously. I feel like I can offer a
unique perspective here as someone who is
both a fan and a creator. As a fan, I try
to separate my bias from my critique. For
example, I don’t really like the concept
of Toy Story 4, because I think the third
was such a perfect ending. But I don’t think
it’s a bad movie. I recognize that it’s
well made for what it is. But when something
is bad, I think it’s important to be vocal
about it in a constructive way. As a fan,
it shows that you care, and a good creator
will take quality criticism into account for
future work.
As a creator, you have to be able to separate
good criticism from comments by those who
were never going to like your content in the
first place. And that brings us to my favorite
cameo in the movie, the Dead Meat cameo, and
this webpage has more hidden content than
you could possibly imagine.
(impact)
♪ Intense Music ♪
For those unaware, the couple behind the “Film
Fails” channel, which Richie can be seen
watching on his laptop, is actually James
A Janisse and his wife, Chelsea -- the hosts
of YouTube biggest horror movie channel, Dead
Meat, who we can actually see a real upload
from in the recommended bar on the right.
It struck me as strange that they would use
a made-up brand for their channel, because
this is a Scream movie. All of the movies
and shows referenced tend to be real movies
and shows from our world, the only exception
being Stab, which is a stand-in for a real
franchise: the Scream franchise.
I figured I might as well go straight to the
source on this one, because I can, so I asked
James why that might be. This is what he had
to say: “Mostly cause we're being a-holes
in it. It's a parody of more toxic YouTube
channels that cover movies, it's not meant
to be us or Dead Meat.” I think this is
a great answer, because it fits right in with
what I was saying earlier about toxic fandom.
These Film Fails characters aren’t saying
anything constructive about the movie, they’re
basically just pouting that it’s not the
Stab that they know and are comfortable with.
And when I think more about it, there is precedent
for this. Sunrise Studios doesn’t exist,
it was just a parody of a predatory movie
studio. KQIS 6 doesn’t exist either, it’s
a parody of bloodthirsty journalism.
Film Fails, more specifically, seems to parody
YouTube channels that screeched about Star
Wars: The Last Jedi in 2017, judging by that
Dead Meat upload on the side: “Rian Johnson
on Reinventing Stab”. Rian Johnson was the
director of that very heavily debated Star
Wars title, and was often the target of that
vitriol from fans and content creators. I’m
sure there are many people that would like
you to believe that The Last Jedi was divisive
or controversial, but if you actually look
at the ratings, most people found it to be
very average.
I already talked about Film Fails’s subscriber
count being Wes Craven’s birthday, but the
view count is also significant. It has 122,096
views; 12/20/96. December 20th, 1996 was the
release date of the original Scream. Then
there’s the like to dislike ratio. It has
1,117 likes and 20 dislikes; 11/17/20 or November
17th, 2020 was the day that production wrapped
on Scream 2022. Thanks to Richie for using
the Return YouTube Dislike extension so we
could see that one.
On the side, there’s a video from Bloody
Disgusting’s YouTube channel that I mentioned
earlier. It’s titled: “Interview with
Woodsboro Survivor Kirby Reed!” Kirby was
a major character in the fourth movie, and
up until now, we were lead to believe that
she didn’t make it, so this is actually
big news!
The fourth video is called “Not My STAB!
Join the StabHead Army and #RedoStab2021!!”
and it’s uploaded by a channel called StabHead.
There’s a bit of a story behind this, so
grab some popcorn. Dreadit is the name of
the horror movie community on Reddit. Mindy
actually mentions it when she’s explaining
the fan contempt for Stab 8.
–[Mindy] You go on 4chan and Dreadit, all they’re
talking about is how Stab 8 pissed on their
childhoods.
– To promote Scream (2022)’s release,
the
team behind the movie held an ask-me-anything
session on Dreadit. One user, named StabHead
asked, “Did
any of the actors go above and beyond to prepare
for their roles?” Their reply said: “We
were meeting with Jack to talk about his character
and he told us that he had created a Reddit
account under the name StabHead to… ...wait
a minute… WE LOVE YOU JACK QUAID!!!”
Necessary information: Jack Quaid is the actor
who played Richie, the second Ghostface killer.
The account shows him commenting on topics
like Halloween, The Last Jedi, and of course,
Scream.
So the way I see it, StabHead is actually
Richie’s online persona. He was the one
to create this channel and upload this video.
Amber even mentions during the finale that
she met Richie on the Stab subreddit. Under
the StabHead upload, there’s one more video
of importance. “Did the real-life Stu Macher
survive?” As I mentioned in my Scream 3
video, the original plan for that movie was
to have Stu return as the villain, but since
this was right after Columbine, producers
decided it was not the best idea to have a
high school revenge seeker right now. But
this video title suggests that maybe having
Stu return in the future is not yet out of
the question. If he is alive, he’s been
in prison for about 25 years now. Although
Stu himself isn’t in the movie, his actor
has yet another vocal cameo here as the voice
of the new silver-faced Ghostface.
–[Matthew] This sh*t is lit!
– One of the common complaints about the
new
Ghostface in Stab (2021) is his new weapon:
a flamethrower. Ironically, the new Ghostface
in this movie ends up getting herself
lit on fire. The link to Film Fails’s merch
store is hastaelfuego.org -- Spanish for until
the fire, which could also be a clue about
Amber’s fate. When she has her one last
scare moment at the end, she’s covered in
burn scars, very reminiscent of Freddy Krueger.
You can bet that that was by design.
About mid-way through the film, the deaths
of Judy and Wes are discovered, and Sam realizes
her sister may be in trouble at the hospital,
so she gives Richie a call to check on her,
and hears an unexpected voice on the other
line.
–[caller] Hello Samantha. Richie can’t come to
the phone right now. He’s finding out what
happens to people who stick their noses in
business that doesn’t concern them.
– It reminds me of Jigsaw re-recording Daniel
Matthews voicemail greeting in Saw 2.
– [Jigsaw] You’ve reached Daniel's phone.
He is
not in right now.
– I love a good horror movie voicemail greeting.
If this was the fourth movie, which had a
lot of Saw references, this might be an intentional
nod to Saw, but this is the fifth movie, which
focuses more on the so-called “elevated
horror” genre. For example, Tara’s favorite
movie is the The Babadook and she begs to
be quizzed on the gems of the mid-to-late
10s.
– [Tara] Ask me about It Follows. Ask me
about Hereditary. Ask me about The VVitch.
– She’s got really good taste! She describes
elevated horror as being “scary but with
complex emotional and thematic underpinnings”,
not just cheesy jump scares, which Richie,
as a fan of Stab, isn’t thrilled with.
– [caller] Sounds kind of boring to me.
– And in the Home Theater scene, Stab’s
slasher
stylings and “elevated horror” are painted
to be opposites. A major reason cited for
fans not liking the newest Stab movie was
the “crammed in social commentary”. So
Richie was upset that his favorite franchise
was trying to ride the trendy wave of elevated
horror, and set out to craft his own entry
more in line with the original by doing a
requel. The huge gaping question that leaves
is: isn’t that exactly what Jill already
tried to do? And yes, it is, the only difference
was their motivations. Jill did it for fame,
but Richie and Amber just wanted to motivate
the creation of another Stab movie -- it
doesn’t seem like being the star was as
important to them.
Even if we are to give them the benefit of
the doubt and say that these killers are an
homage to Scre4m, rather than copying it,
there are still a couple of details necessary
to make it make sense, which I didn’t fully
realize on my first viewing. The first is
that there is no Stab movie based on Scre4m.
If there was, Richie and Amber probably wouldn’t
have felt the need to make a new one. At the
time of Scre4m there are 7 Stab movies, and
in this movie, there’s only one new one,
hence the #RedoStab8.
Then, there’s the fact that the original
Scream, and really all the Scream movies do
feature some kind of social commentary -- which
I’ve taken time to discuss in each of my
Things You Missed™ videos. So why would
Richie
be upset about the new Stab having social
commentary? This is because in the Scream
universe, the Stab movies are considered non-fiction.
Nobody is making up the plot, so nothing that
happens qualifies as commentary.
–[Richie] Because that’s how you make a great
Stab movie, Sam. “Based on actual events”.
– And this ties right back into the theme
of
toxic fandom: Richie believes each Stab movie
must be like the original. That’s why there
are so many repeated elements from the original
Scream. Like when Tara is trying to defend
herself at the hospital.
(Tara grunts)
–[Richie] Ow! Ahh! God dammnit.
Did you hit me with a phone?
–[Tara] LOOKOUT!
– Must have been thrilling for Richie to
be
reliving events from the original Stab.
– [Sidney] You’ve gotta find me first
you pansy-***
momma’s boy!
– [Billy] ****
– [Stu] You ****ing hit me with a phone,
****.
– In some cases lines are nearly lifted
directly
from a previous movie.
– [caller] You think you're still the star.
– [Sidney] This isn't a f*cking movie!
– [caller] It will be.
– [Sam] This isn’t a f*cking movie.
– [Richie] No, but it will be…
– The final act features plenty more references,
some of which you might have noticed, but
you probably missed this tiny detail, which
was the reason Mindy was able to survive where
others did not.
–[Amber] Welcome to Act 3.
–[Richie] RUN!
(impact)
♪ Suspenseful Music ♪
– Before we get to the final act, let’s
talk
about Dewey. His fatal mistake is shooting
Amber’s bulletproof armor rather than hitting
her in the head. He realizes it a little too
late. In Scream 3 he makes the same mistake
with Roman, but Sidney is there to remind
him to aim for the head. This time she isn’t,
and Dewey pays the price.
Given Dewey’s ability to survive seemingly
fatal blows in the past, I wasn’t convinced
that he was really done for this time. We’ve
seen this scene before. However, the more
I look at it, the more I think he really might
be gone this time. He’s being taken to the
coroner this time, not the ambulance. I doubt
the coroner would be called unless some medical
professional was really sure that he was dead.
– [Amber] Dewey had to die to make it real.
To show that this wasn’t just some bullsh*t,
cash-in, run of the mill sequel.
– Well, this is awkward.
It also fits the blueprint of a requel. When
the cast is talking about requels, Mindy brings
up Star Wars: The Force Awakens as an example.
There will be spoilers for Star Wars: The
Force Awakens here, so if you don’t want
to hear them, skip forward to the next chapter.
The Force Awakens is all about passing the
torch to a new set of characters. Luke, Leia
and Han are passing it off to Rey, Fin and
Poe. This is accentuated by the death of a
legacy character: Han Solo. So Scream (2022)
is doing the same here by killing off Dewey
as the torch is passed from Sidney, Dewey
and Gale to Sam, Tara, Mindy and Chad.
And just as The Force Awakens brought back
familiar locations like The Millenium Falcon
and The Starkiller, which is basically The
Death Star, Scream (2022) brings back the
Macher household, which plays host to another
party, which is probably the most tasteless
thing ever, considering it’s supposedly
supposed to honor their friend Wes, but it
looks like a typical college party. I guess
it’s kind of fitting though, considering
the existence of this movie.
Here we see a few more callbacks. The basement
fridge is the new garage fridge.
–[Robert] Not many people have basements in California.
– Richie is wearing a blue plaid shirt,
just
like former Woodsboro killers Billy Loomis
and Jill Roberts. When Sidney arrives, the
first door she checks behind is the same one
she hid inside when she donned the Ghostface
mask in the original Scream. Perhaps the most
obvious repeat is the infamous, “look behind
you” scene, which we’ve seen play out
in various forms across most Scream movies.
Mindy is the new Randy, so fittingly, she’s
the one being snuck up on, but unlike Randy,
she realizes it and attempts to get out of
the way. This is partially because she knows
she’s in a movie and she might be a little
bit sharper than Randy, but there’s also
an important clue in Stab.
There are a couple of VHS tapes on the table
behind Stab Randy. I think the top one might
be The People Under Stairs, another Wes Craven
reference, and I’m having a hard time making
out what the bottom one is, let me know if
you recognize it. But look directly below
the TV she’s watching on, and you’ll see
the same three VHS tapes, two of which are
the same two on the table behind Randy. There’s
a slightly better look a bit later, when Sam
is tending to Mindy’s injuries, it’s definitely
the same two tapes.
Mindy, by the way, does survive, which could
be related to this little line from Scre4m.
– [Charlie] In fact, the only surefire way
to survive
a modern horror movie, you pretty much have
to be gay.
– [Zac] It also helps to be the daughter
of a serial
killer, as it turns out. She may be related
to Billy Loomis, but Sam wipes off her knife
a lot more like Stu Macher.
Now before I get into the ending, and my views
on what this really means for the franchise,
I’ve got to go over all the evidence seen
throughout the film that proves who the killers
really were, as I have at the end of each
of my Scream analysis videos. So let’s take
it back one more time to the start.
In the opening, Tara invites Amber to come
over, mentioning that her Mom was out of town.
Amber and Richie were probably waiting for
an opportunity like this and used it to decide
that this would be the night they strike.
When Tara starts receiving concerning phone
calls, she gets a text from Amber, which says
“you should answer it.” The caller explains
that Amber’s phone was cloned and no one
really questions it. But the easier and correct
explanation is that Amber was just the killer,
using her own phone. When Sam gets a Ghostface
call at the hospital, it’s also from
Amber’s phone.
Amber and Richie have to act like they are
meeting for the first time. We see her look
at him very lustfully, which makes more sense
now knowing that they are secretly a couple.
Sam is attacked at the hospital at the same
time Amber was being questioned by Hicks at
the police station, which means this one must
have been Richie. This is the same old trick
used to get Billy Loomis off the hook in Scream,
get Roman off the hook in Scream 3. When are
they gonna learn that there are always multiple
killers?
Then there’s the scene where Dewey correctly
predicts a killer by accusing Richie. This
is just like Randy in the original Scream,
his first guess is Billy, and it’s correct.
–[Randy] He’s got killer printed all over his
forehead.
– The most damning evidence comes after
he kicks
Richie and Sam out though. Listen to what
Richie has to say about him.
–[Richie] Jesus! Yeah he’s way more fun in the
movies.
– Notice the plural use of the word: movies.
At this point in the story, he claims that
he’s only seen one Stab movie, the original.
When he and Sam were driving to Woodsboro
he claimed to have no idea about the Stab
movies, and in the hospital, he says he’s
watching the first one on Netflix so he can
be prepared. Lucky for him, Sam doesn’t
seem to notice this slip up.
While it’s not necessarily evidence, I do
think the fact that he spends his spare time
watching vitriol about Stab (2021) kind of
telling about where his interests lie, even
if his reasoning is that he’s trying to
learn about the franchise.
Later on, during the second attack at the
hospital, Amber cuts Richie in the forearm.
We saw this in Scre4m, where Jill was cut
in the same spot by her fellow accomplice
as a way to deflect suspicion away from her.
In my previous video, I labeled this as a
nod to Scream 2, where Derek is cut in the
forearm, and Dewey finds it suspicious because
the cut conveniently missed major arteries.
Despite some of the well hidden evidence I
mentioned, I found these killers to be pretty
obvious. Perhaps the fact that they are so
similar to the killers from the last movie
made them stand out a little bit more.
We close with the same pull out shot of a
news anchor giving a report in front of the
house, but this time it is not Gale Weathers.
Like the main characters and the filmmakers,
the news anchor microphone has been passed
down to the next generation.
At the end, over the dedication to the series’
late former director, we hear a bird call.
(whip-poor-will call)
It links back to all the bird artwork seen
in Amber’s house. It’s all part of one
last tribute to Scream’s iconic director,
Wes Craven, who, in his spare time, was an
avid birdwatcher.
The sound at the end of Scream (2022) is the
call of the whip-poor-will, a sound effect
that Craven has actually used a few times
in his films. In this 2008 interview in the
bird enthusiast magazine Audubon, he explains
how he has used bird sounds as a sort of orchestration
in his work. “I’ve used the whip-poor-will
a few times, probably inappropriately, but
it’s such a haunting sound, and I do remember
the sound from being a kid in the woods of
Ohio and on camping trips. But yeah, I think
they’re used a lot in Hollywood. I would
be the first to confess that accuracy is probably
not the first motivation.”
We get a quick flash of someone in a Ghostface
mask wiping off a knife before the credits
roll, maybe an homage to the quick scares
seen before the credits of Scream
(stinger)
and in Scream 2
(knives slashing and screaming)
No such scare occurs in
Scream 3 or 4. To me, the implication is that
seeing a new Ghostface right before the end
credits
is teasing a sequel. We don’t see it in
3 because Roman is defeated, and for now that
means the end of the series. While Scream
4 was not planned to be the final movie, it
was the end of that era of Scream and there’s
nothing in the story that prevents the fourth
movie from being the final chapter, unlike
Scream 1, which specifically has a line about
how there’s gotta be a sequel, and Scream
2, which specifically has a line suggesting
that it’s a trilogy.
So the quick flash of Ghostface at the end
of Scream (2022), to me, is the directors’
way of telling us they planned for a sequel,
and with a sixth movie being given the go-ahead
before the fifth was even globally released,
it seems likely the next chapter was planned
and will tie in nicely with the material in
the 2022 offering.
(IMPACT)
Towards the end of Scream VI, we see a quick
shot of the contacts list on
Sam's phone, one of which is Kristy.
In my Scream 2022 video, I pointed out the
Easter eggs hidden in the
contacts on Dewey's phone and the meaning
behind Kristy and the other names listed.
So this is our clue to be on the lookout for
references again.
So let's go through her contacts.
Tara is her sister, the Jenna Ortega character.
But Meyer is the son of Scream VI producer
William Sherak.
The next name is Eloise. She's the daughter
of William Sherak.
The next name after that is Niky.
The fifth and 6th Scream were directed by
Matt Bettinelli-Olpin and Tyler Gillett
who did a segment in the anthology horror
film VHS where one of
the characters is named Niky.
I'm not sure about River, it's too common
of a word to search, but I did
figure out that Eileen is Eileen Jones, the
wife of Tyler Gillett.
Mindy and Chad are the twins from the movie.
Sidney is the main protagonist of the franchise
who isn't in this one.
Jay is the film's editor.
Jay Prychidny, and T Ferg is the post production
assistant,
Tyler Ferguson.
I wasn't able to find a Minnie, and Rebecca
could refer to several people.
But that's just a taste of the level of detail
that this movie's secrets have to offer.
If you want to know the Scream origins of
every single prop in the
movie theater shrine, all of the costume references
on the subway train and
info hidden in hard to find places, stick
around to the end of this video.
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Just one year after the franchise was revived
with Scream 2022, the next
sequel would already be released, mirroring
the quick turnaround from the
original Scream in 1996 to Scream 2 in 1997.
This would be our first of many clues that
Scream VI was going to be a
requel of Scream 2 in the same way that the
last movie was a recall of the original.
For the third movie in a row, they changed
the naming convention
of the title.
The fourth movie moved the number inside the
word Scream, which was cool.
Everybody likes it when I call it Scre4m.
It's not annoying, and nobody leaves angry
comments about that at all.
The fifth could have gone with 5cream, but
instead it just decided to
call it Scream to fit the meta of recalls
at the time,
like Halloween and Candy Man.
I guess Scream VI was trying to do the best
of both worlds by doing the
standalone title, but also having the number
in the M on the poster,
which means they had to switch to Roman numerals.
It reminds me of the Jak franchise.
The first game was Jak and Daxter: The Precursor
Legacy.
Then Jak II switches to Roman numerals.
Jack 3 used Arabic numerals, but then the
fourth one was called Jax X,
but it wasn't the Roman numeral X, it was
just the letter X.
Anyway, I'm getting off topic.
Let's cut in to the Things You Missed.
♪ Ominous Music ♪
The first thing I'm going to talk about is
how similar this movie is to
Scream 2.
While the characters do point this out themselves
-[Sam]Stab 2 took place in college.
-[Tara] So do we think that the killer is
trying to copy the movies?
It goes much deeper than you might have realized.
In addition to the college setting, one of
the five Ghostface killers in
this movie, Jason, is introduced in the opening
where we find out that he's
a student in a class about 20th century slashers.
Just like the killer in Scream 2, Mickey is
introduced in the college film
class discussing the Stab movie.
Both movies feature a main character who's
dealing with newfound fame after
surviving murders the previous year.
When a new string of crimes begins, they're
both given special police protection.
Each has a new boyfriend who's very suspicious
but not guilty.
When we're reintroduced to Tara, she's on
her way to a party
-[Tara]She went to the Omega Kappa Beta party.
It's the same fraternity that Derek belonged
to in Scream 2.
We even briefly see their coat of arms that
matches the necklace that Derek
gave Sidney.
At the party, we learned that Tara is considering
joining sorority called Omega Beta Zeta.
-[Frat Guy] You omega beta zeta.
-[Tara] No, not yet.
Which is the same one that CiCi Cooper
was a part of in 1997.
Speaking of CiCi Cooper,
she doesn't last long in the movie, getting
stabbed and thrown off
the top of that sorority house.
She has a counterpart in Scream VI, Anika
who gets stabbed and tossed from
the ladder she's trying to escape on.
I don't know why Danny just has a huge ladder
in his NYC apartment.
Maybe he saw Nerve and was inspired.
Tara later explains that the Core Four moved
to New York for summer semester,
very similar to how Sidney and Randy moved
to Ohio mid-school year
to escape their own trauma in Woodsboro.
While Scream 2 was set in Ohio, the college
that they filmed at was in Atlanta.
Atlanta is mentioned several times in Scream
VI.
It's the place where Jason and Greg first
met in middle school and
Kirby works for the FBI's Atlanta field office.
Could be a coincidence, or maybe an intentional
connection.
Kirby, by the way, has a scar from where Charlie
stabbed her in Scre4m.
She gets stabbed there again at the end of
Scream VI, but lives.
The same way that Dewey survived in Scream
2.
-[Paramedic] Knife went into most scar tissue.
Saved his life.
The same thing seems to happen to Gale Weathers.
In Scre4m, she got it in the shoulder and
that's where the new Ghostface
gets her again in Six, and she manages to
survive.
After Sam and Tara survive the first attack,
Gale Weathers comes
investigating and the franchise tradition
of her getting punched in the face
by the victim continues.
If you look at the reaction of the cameraman,
it's the same look of surprise
seen on the face of Joel, her camera guy in
Scream 2.
– ♪ Yes I got that on film! ♪
The reason Gale got punched was because Sam
was unhappy with her portrayal
in Gale's latest Book.
-[Sam] You called me unstable and a born killer.
-[Gale] That's taken out of context.
-[Sam] That's literally a quote.
which mirrors Dewey's frustrations with his
portrayal in the Woodsboro Murders book.
He, too, supplies her with actual citations.
-[Dewey] Page 41.
As I mentioned, the first death out of the
main cast is Anika, and she's
wearing the same green jacket that Randy wore
when he became a Ghostface
victim in the second movie.
There's also another reference to Randy when
they're walking through the park,
trying to keep Ghostface on the line.
And this similarity is called out by Mindy.
-[Mindy] This is exactly how our Uncle Randy
died.
However, the person in danger here is actually
Gale, who is at home.
During her call with the killer,
she tries to locate him by hanging up and
calling back.
This is also a reference to Scream 2.
-[Maureen] Hang the phone up as *69 his ***. Damn.
The finale of each film takes
place in a theater where all is revealed.
At one point, Sam grabs a brick to defend
herself with, which honors the
method by which Sidney tried to defeat Billy's
mother, crushing her with a
pile of bricks.
Quinn reveals herself as the final killer.
-[Quinn] Hey my roomies. You didn’t see
that one coming, did you?
Actually, I did. Billy and Roman already tried
faking their deaths, so it wasn't a huge surprise.
More importantly, her line is almost identical
to what Mickey said
after the reveal of Billy's mother.
-[Roman] Nice twist, huh? Didn't see it coming,
did ya?
Like in Scream 2, the main Ghostface the parent
of the antagonist from the
previous movie, out for revenge against their
son's killer.
The accomplice, or in this case, the accomplices
are enrolled at the
university, their education being funded by
the other Ghostface.
In Scream 2, Sidney is saved by Cotton, someone
she previously believed to
be guilty.
In Six, Sam and Tara are saved by Kirby, who
they thought was guilty.
Finally, at the end, it turns out that Chad
is somehow alive, and he's
carried out in a stretcher with Tara running
alongside.
It's just like Dewey and Gale at the end of
Scream 2.
But there would be even more Scream 2 references
in the movie theater,
along with many more hidden secrets.
(Thunder)
Are you on a mission to make healthier choices
this summer?
Are you on a mission to quote every 2000s
teen movie ever?
This summer is going to be different.
This summer is going to change our lives.
If you want to make calorie conscious eating
a breeze without compromising
on tastes, check out Factor. Their delicious,
dietitian approved calorie
smart meals come with around 550 calories
per serving so you can enjoy your
favorite meals guilt free, knowing that you're
staying on track with your
health goals.
And here's something for those of you looking
to budget this month by
cutting back on takeout. Why not try Factor
instead? Not only is Factor more
affordable than takeout, but their chef prepared
meals already faster than
restaurant delivery in just two minutes.
That's right.
In less than the time it takes to choose a
movie, your gourmet meal can be
ready to eat.
As you may know, I've also worked with HelloFresh,
who owns Factor, and I'm
a fan of both. HelloFresh for when I want
to cut things,
and Factor for when I'm in a hurry, which
is often.
As a CZsWorld viewer, you'll get a discount
on both brands.
Ready to make the smart choice this summer?
Click the link in the
description, or go to Factor 75 dot com and
use code CZ50 to get 50% off your
first Factor box.
That's Factor 75 dot com with code CZ50 for
50% off the already affordable price.
This summer's gonna be different.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Part of the fun of the Scream franchise and
the whodunit genre in general
is going back to see the clues laid out for
us once we know the ending.
In Tara's dialogue with Quinn at the apartment,
Quinn describes how her dad
held on too tight with overprotectiveness
after they lost her brother.
Combine that with Detective Bailey's line
after Quinn's death.
-[Detective Bailey] Both my kids are gone,
my whole family is gone.
And that's two oddly specific references to
this mysterious dead sibling.
The movie honestly could have used a few red
herrings to throw us off
because it was obvious that this brother was
significant.
Add in the fact that the first Ghostface call
comes from Richie Kirsch's
phone, and it starts to become clear.
This is the same tactic that Richie and Amber
used.
When a call came in from Amber's phone,
everyone assumed that the killer cloned Amber's
phone number,
when in reality, all they had to do was use
Amber's actual phone.
Detective Bailey probably got Richie's phone
back after his death and just
used that. One area where the movie did successfully
employ a red herring was
in wardrobe.
Fans know at this point that at least one
Ghostface killer always has a
light blue shirt or flannel.
In this case, it was Ethan,
and while I never really suspected Tara or
Sam, we're forced to notice Danny
wearing light blue when we literally see him
put it on.
Someone wearing a Ghostface mask attacks Sam
and Tara outside their apartment,
the same apartment where they were literally
just with Quinn and Ethan.
Later on, after Quinn's death is staged, her
father comes out of the
building with a little bit of a limp, maybe
from an injury sustained when
he's knocked to the floor by Samantha.
And he's staring right at Samantha as he says
this.
-[Detective Bailey] You f*** with my family,
you die.
And when Gale gets the dreaded phone call
later on.
It's from a 707 area code, which represents
Northern California, where
Woodsboro is located.
That's another clue that the killer is from
that area, which Richie's family
most likely would be.
There's also an ominous clue that isn't related
to the identity of the protagonist.
Sam's psychiatrist can be seen watching Invasion
of the Body Snatchers
which literally tells him before he becomes
the next Ghostface victim.
As always, it's one of many horror movie references
in a Scream film.
Every Scream movie makes a reference to Psycho,
with the last film
even containing a Psycho movie poster. That
continues here with this poster
in Jason's apartment.
He also has a Vertigo poster, another thriller
directed by Alfred Hitchcock.
In addition to the first Psycho, Psycho Two
is also referenced this time.
–[Mindy & Kirby] Psycho II is underrated.
Psycho Two also features a character getting
stabbed through the mouth,
which is exactly what Tara does to Ethan at
the end.
But going back to Jason, given that he's a
film student and a horror fan,
there are a lot of references connected to
him.
The reason he killed his professor in the
opening sequence was because she
gave him a C-minus on his Giallo paper.
Giallo is an Italian murder mystery genre,
a perfect counterpart to Scream.
Jason's t-shirt says 4 Mosche On Velluto Grigio,
which translates to
four flies on the gray velvet.
It's a Giallo film directed by Dario Argento
about a rock musician who
becomes entangled in a gruesome murder case.
Interestingly, Jason also has an Ice Nine
Kills magnet on his fridge.
Ice Nine Kills is a metal band known for theming
their songs around horror movies.
Their 2018 album, The Silver Scream has a
series of accompanying
music videos with a narrative through line
about a series of deaths connected
to the band's frontman Spencer Charnas.
So kind of similar to Four Flies on the Gray
Velvet. Ice Nine Kills also did
a deluxe version of The Silver Scream, which
appropriately contains a song
about Scream.
And no, it was not lost on me that Jason gets
home and turns on a
Friday the 13th movie.
His full name is Jason Carvey, and Jason Voorhees,
the antagonist of the
Friday the 13th franchise, likes to carve
up his victims.
This isn't just any Friday the 13th movie,
though.
It's Friday the 13th Part VIII: Jason Takes
Manhattan.
The one where he goes to New York.
Much like how Scream VI is set in New York.
Jason is not the only new character who seems
to be a horror fan.
Sam's psychiatrist has some merch in his office.
On the desk, you can spot a lineup of horror
dolls, including Gomez, Pugsley
and Fester Addams, as well as Leatherface.
Above the fireplace, there's also a Leatherface
doll and a Ghostface doll.
The defunct movie theater marquee is advertising
two events.
On the left, it says Jennifer Jolie Retrospective.
Jennifer Jolie was the name of the actress
who played Gale Weathers in Stab 3.
On the right, it says Rocky Horror Picture
Show, which connects to
this guy dressed up as Frank-n-Furter from
Rocky Horror on the subway.
Which brings me to the next section the costumes.
It's always been a pet peeve of mine in movies
that take place around
Halloween, when everyone is dressed in generic
costumes like vampire,
pirate, nurse, et cetera, because in real
life, most people are dressed up
as something specific, usually some kind of
pop culture thing.
I was glad to see Scream finally do this right
and some of the costumes have a deeper meaning.
Like at the Omega Kappa Beta party,
where we see a girl dressed as Wednesday Addams
from The Addams family.
Since the release of Scream 2022, the star
Jenna Ortega portrayed this
character in a popular adaptation known as
Wednesday.
Is the recycling Wednesday flyer on her fridge
related to this as well?
Probably not.
Other party guests include someone in a striped
Ghostface mask hanging with
Dwight Schrute from The Office.
There's also a girl in the crowd wearing a
number ten jersey, a reference to
the top that Tatum wears in the first Scream,
which is a reference to what
Glen Lantz wore in A Nightmare on Elm Street.
Then we've got Harry Potter, Alan from The
Hangover, and Mindy Meeks, who is
dressed as Stormé DeLarverie, a woman known
for her part in a lesbian
movement in the 1960s.
That's kind of her whole entire gimmick in
this movie.
She's constantly advertising her homosexuality.
There are even more costumes in the subway
scene.
First, there's Grace from the 2019 movie Ready
or Not, which is directed by
Matt Bettinelli-Olpin and Tyler Gillett.
Just like this movie, there's a David Bowie
in the crowd and a Michael Myers
from the Halloween franchise, which is significant
because of how the Scream
franchise is a satire primarily of the Halloween
franchise.
In fact, when they arrive at the train station,
you can hear people chanting, Evil dies tonight.
-[Jason] Less scary serial killer movie.
Which is the mantra from Halloween, kills
the sequel to the requel.
Just like how Scream VI is a sequel to a requel.
The Statue of Liberty makes an appearance.
Makes sense.
It's New York.
This is Mojo Jojo, the main villain from the
Powerpuff Girls.
Nice to see Scream staying in touch with its
90s roots.
It's not really a costume, but this guy has
a Fangoria shirt.
Fangoria being the famous horror magazine.
On the train, there's someone dressed as The
Babadook, which Tara cited as
her favorite movie in the fifth Scream.
-[Ghostface] What's your favorite scary movie?
-[Tara] The Babadook.
Other than Ghostface, the train contains a
variety of other slasher icons,
like Pinhead from the Hellraiser movies, Jason
from Friday the 13th, and
Freddie Krueger from A Nightmare on Elm Street.
Of course, this wasn't Freddie's first rodeo
in a Scream movie.
There's also someone dressed as Chucky from
Child's Play, which was
referenced in Scream 2022 as an example of
a horror movie that was remade.
That scene also talks about elevated Horror.
-[Amber]What's wrong with elevated horror?
I mean, Jordan Peele fucking rules.
So some of the costumes in the subway are
from the elevated horror era, like
Pluto from Jordan Peele's US, as well as several
of the other tethered
characters from that movie.
There's also a chick dressed as Dani Ardor,
aka The May Queen from Midsommar.
Right after that, there's a quick flash cameo
from Tyler Gillett,
the co-director, before we move on to some
Stephen King references.
Including the Grady twins from The Shining
and Georgie Denbrough
from IT.
Other horror references include Melanie Daniels
from The Birds, complete with Bird,
Horace Pinker from Wes Craven's Shocker, Kayako
Saeki from The Grudge,
and Billy the Puppet from Saw, which was mentioned
in Scre4m.
-[Trudie] Did you pick a movie?
-[Sherrie] Yeah, we're going to go scary,
Saw 4.
It seems there are also other pop culture
references on the train, like Tyler Durden
from Fight Club, and I didn't know what this
was, so I tried Googling hand
around a neck costume, and apparently this
was just an Oscars dress from
Julia Fox, an actress from the movie Uncut
Gems.
There's one glaring hole in the train scene.
They're trying to safely travel from the Upper
West Side to the movie theater
Everyone is in costume around them, so why
don't they just get
costumes to evade Ghostface? There are many
hidden details in the costumes,
and there may even be some that I didn't recognize,
so let me know what you
saw in the comments.
But there are even more secrets in the form
of hidden Wes Craven homages,
Scream easter eggs, and other things you might
have missed.
(Thunder)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
If you follow my channel,
you know I am very concerned with movie timeline
accuracy.
I have a series called Horror History, which
is half character analysis and
half timeline construction, so I can be the
first to say that these last two
Scream movies have screwed up the timeline.
At the end of the fifth Scream, the reporter
claims that the original
Woodsboro Massacre was 25 years ago, almost
to the day.
The original was set in 1996, so that would
mean that it was set in 2021.
However, Sam and Mindy both claim that the
most recent Stab came out last year,
and we can clearly see that was 2021, meaning
that the fifth Scream is
actually set in 2022, which seems to be backed
up in Scream VI.
The Woodsboro Truther subreddit refers to
the most recent events in
Woodsboro as the 2022 Woodsboro Massacre,
and Kirby's timeline of
events says 2022 was the year of Richie and
Amber's death.
However, this board also claims that Roman's
death was in 2000, which is incorrect.
In Scream 3, Roman died in 1999.
The production designers obviously just use
the release dates of the movies
rather than when they are set, but Kirby specifically
says that Richie and
Amber died last year.
So we can probably just go with the fifth
Scream taking place in 2022, and
the sixth Scream taking place in 2023, right?
Well, when we see the film professor's phone
at the beginning of the
movie, it says Saturday, October 29, which
would put this in 2022.
Other phone screens also corroborate this.
Sam's driver's license is two days away from
expiration, although you could
argue that she's not planning on renewing
it because you don't need a car in
New York.
And the subway map says service suspended
through September 2022.
Why would that still be up over a year later?
But on the other hand, the
newscaster in Scream VI very clearly refers
to Sam as...
-[Reporter] One of the survivors of the Woodsboro
killings in 2022.
So I think there's more evidence now that
Scream 2022 does in fact take
place in 2022, and Scream VI takes place 13
months later in 2023.
This board also confirms that the Scream TV
show is a separate canon
entirely, which I'm very much fine with.
Look, if anyone knows the people that work
on these movies, can you please
just send them my channel so they can stop
screwing up their own franchise?
I usually try to find a reason to make the
mistakes work by saying things
like, this character was just estimating the
date, but there are only so
many excuses I can make for you.
-[Kirby] Roman Bridger was the only single
Ghostface.
-[Kirby] Kudos to him for ambition.
That's debatable.
It's extremely debatable.
See my Scream 3 Things You Missed episode
for details, but not until
after you've seen all the Wes Craven references
here in Scream VI.
As you know, Wes craven was the legendary
horror director who brought us
everything from Last House on the Left, to
The Hills Have Eyes, to
A Nightmare on Elm Street.
And, of course, the first four Scream. In
Jason's apartment,
he has up a poster for Last Podcast on the
Left, a clear play on
Last House on the Left.
That film was released in 1972, and in the
establishing shots at the
beginning of the movie, we see West 72nd street.
It appears that all of the east-west streets
in Upper Manhattan corresponds
to Wes Craven release dates.
The characters board a train at 94th and 93rd,
which corresponds to
New Nightmare and Body Bags, respectively.
Gale's apartment is located between 96th and
97th.
Scream came out in 1996, and Scream 2 came
out in 1997.
One of the posts in the Woodsboro Truther
subreddit,
comes from a user named
234Mimimimi23.
Mimi Craven was Wes Craven's wife for a short
time
in the 80s.
She appeared in A Nightmare on Elm Street
and Swamp Thing.
Jason and Greg's apartment building is called
Elmcourt, a reference to a
Nightmare on Elm Street when we see Sam's
driver's license
her address is 2419 Solar Drive, Modesto,
California.
However, this address is not in Modesto.
It's in Los Angeles, and it once belonged
to Wes Craven.
This next one is one of the weirdest ever.
At the end of the convenience store scene,
we see the exterior of the store,
and it's called Abe's Snake Bodega.
When I'm making these videos and I see a brand
name that I don't
recognize, I always look it up to find out
if there's some significance.
So that's what I did.
And I found this Slashfilm article which contains
some odd trivia.
It explains that one of Craven's friends got
involved in producing adult
films in the 70's and he decided to try making
one himself.
In 1975, in between the Last House and 1977s
the Hills Have Eyes, Craven made
The Fireworks Woman, also known as Angela
the Fireworks Woman using a
spectacular pseudonym Abe Snake.
And just like Angela was packed with fireworks,
Scream VI is packed with
Easter eggs, referencing the rest of the Scream
franchise.
If you look closely at the Woodsboro truther
subreddit, which, by the
way, the URL is www.r/woodsborotruther
Pretty sure that's not how URLs work, but
you'll notice
that the sub was created 1/14/2022.
This contradicts the timeline again, but at
least this one is obviously just
an Easter egg.
It's technically the theatrical release date
of Scream 2022, seen on posters.
Even though the premiere was canceled.
Another Reddit post advertises.
261 Turner Lane Part II.
The All New True Story this is essentially
a story
about the last movie's events because 261
Turner Lane is the
address of the house once occupied by Stu
Macher and his family, before being
the host of Amber Freeman and her family.
-[Amber] I'm at Stu Macher's house on Turner
Lane.
-[Amber] It's 261
-[Amber] Turner Lane.
Despite leaving Woodsboro, some of the characters
still seem to have
pride about their old town.
Chad hangs onto his letterman jacket and Mindy
wears a panther patch on
hers, the mascot of Woodsboro High.
One of the defining characteristics of a requel
is rehashing existing
scenes, and Scream VI is no exception.
Sam and Tara visit the police station following
their convenience store
encounter, where they're told that they can't
leave town by the detectives.
In the fourth Scream, Dewey and Judy have
to tell Sidney the same thing.
Another Sidney parallel can be seen as they're
leaving and the media swarm
around them, just like when they mobbed Sidney
Prescott in 1996 outside of
the Woodsboro police station.
And the same music plays as well.
Eventually, Kirby shows up, now a member of
the FBI, and she and Mindy test
each other on horror movie knowledge.
– [Kirby] Best Nightmare on Elm Street?
– [Both] The original.
This is a reference to the original Scream,
where Casey Becker has similar taste.
-[Casey] Yeah, Freddie Krueger.
-[Ghostface] Freddie. That's right.
-[Ghostface] I like that movie.
-[Ghostface] It was scary.
-[Casey] Wow. The first one was, but the rest
sucks.
Or maybe just common sense.
Then there's Gale.
During the part where she's talking with Sam
about the importance of family,
we hear Dewey's theme in the background, suggesting
that Gale never stopped
caring about him.
This is also evident because she has the same
photo of her and Dewey that we
first saw in Dewey's trailer in the fifth
one.
She almost ended up joining him after an ambush
by Quinn.
At one point, she fires two shots through
the door and says
-[Gale] How's that for nostalgia, ******?
Referring to when she played hero by shooting
Billy Loomis way back in the original.
But it wasn't just the dialogue that was nostalgic,
because the movie
theater shrine is packed with background detail
spanning the entire
franchise.
(Thunder)
♪ Synth Music ♪
Before heading into the theater for the final
showdown, Sam splits off from
her new love interest, Danny, for safety reasons.
-[Sam] We don't know you? Not really.
She says this in almost the exact same way
as her old love interest.
Richie, spoke about the Stab franchise.
-[Richie] No one has made a great Stab movie
since the first one.
-[Richie] Not really.
From this point on, there's a lot of familiar
line delivery.
-[Ethan] I've always wanted to stick something
in you, Tara.
–[Stu] I always had a thing for you Sid!
The movie theater shrine is a gold mine for
Things You Missed, akin to
Eleanor's studio from Jigsaw.
I'll start with the first Scream and work
my way forward.
This is the outfit Tatum Riley wore on her
final night.
This is Stu Macher's robe from the night of
his party.
And here's Billy Loomis's shirt from that
same evening.
The black jacket and backwards hat belong
to Kenny,
Gale's Cameraman for Top Story with Gale Weathers.
It's more obvious when you see the back of
his Top Story jacket.
This mannequin represents Stephen Orth, Casey's
boyfriend and the franchise's
first onscreen Kill.
Here we have the Ghostface mask that Principal
Henry confiscated from the
pranksters at the school and cut up.
And these are the scissors he used to do it.
-[Principal Henry] Two of your fellow students
just savagely murdered,
-[Principal Henry] and this is the way that
you show your compassion and sensitivity.
-[Principal Henry] Let me show you something.
-[Principal Henry] You're both expelled. Get
out.
You know, I wonder if they just showed up
at school the next day.
It's not like Henry had time to tell anyone
that he expelled them.
On top of the mask is the rope that Henry
swung from next to a sketch of
where he was found on the football fields
and his obituaries.
This is an employee shirt from Bradley Video
Store, the store that Randy
worked at in the first movie.
I'm not positive why this is here, because
as far as we know, nobody died at
the video store.
But I guess it's possible that it was still
a scene in the movie adaptation
of Stab.
Rounding out the first movie, we have the
Woodsboro High School Flag.
Scream 2 opens with the Stab movie premiere,
and there's a lot of
memorabilia from that.
We see the costumes, masks and plastic knives
that were handed out to
patrons in attendance at the premiere, as
well as a few
movie tickets.
In the corner is the giant Ghostface head
that decorated the production
office in Scream 3.
This sketch depicts Sidney at various points
in Scream 2 on stage, in the
government car, and at the library.
It's above a Windsor College sweater.
The setting of Scream 2. I believe the camera
that Chad picks up and
throws at Ghostface is Joel's camera during
his gig with Up to Date.
This big old set piece along the side of the
theater is the thing that Derek
was tied to at the end of Scream 2.
And at some point, we can even see the Agamemnon
mask that he was wearing
when he was lowered onto the stage.
There's also another mask from that play right
here.
There's also a glimpse of the white blazer
that Debbie Salt, Nancy Loomis,
was wearing during the finale, and I believe
this is the gun that she used
during that scene.
Scream 3 is all about the production of the
third Stab movie being
terrorized by a new threat.
Above the Stab 3 script is the slate used
during filming.
However, as an Easter egg, the cinematographer
is listed as Brett Jutkiewicz,
the cinematographer of Scream 2022 and Scream
VI.
I spotted a sketch of Sarah Darling, the first
Scream 3 victim, and
Jennifer Jolie, the actress who played Gale.
Also visible here is the killer's voice changer
and gun.
Scream 3 had a special voice changer that
allowed the user to imitate
anyone's voice.
Kind of funny that we've only just recently
unlocked that technology today,
and it's being used to make politicians bicker
over video games.
In this case, there's a melted phone, a frying
pan and a lighter.
The frying pan is the one that the killer
used to knock out the security
guard, Stephen Stone.
There's another frying pan attack in this
movie when Gale uses it against Quinn.
I wonder if that one will make the next museum.
The phone is Jennifer Jolie's phone, damaged
when her house exploded.
And the lighter must have been Tom Prince's
lighter, which was responsible
for causing that explosion.
Overhead is the banner that says, Happy Birthday,
Roman, which was displayed
over the entryway of John Milton's Manor when
Sidney arrived.
It was not a happy birthday for Roman... Scre4m.
By the time this one rolled around, several
more Stab films had been made.
These posters for Stabs Three, Four and Five
are all in Scre4m, but this
is the first time we've ever seen the Stab
Four poster, or should I say the
St4b poster, unobstructed.
There are also sketches of the two killers,
Charlie and Jill, as well as the
shirt that Charlie was wearing when he died
and the flannel that Jill had on
before being taken to the hospital and changed
into a hospital gown.
There's a moment where we see Kirby looking
at it with tears in her eyes,
remembering the way that her best friend betrayed
her and tried to have her killed.
And we also see the knife that Charlie stabbed
her with and the
residue on the patio where Kirby was tied
up.
In the back, here you'll see the outfit worn
by Jill's ex-boyfriend, Trevor, when he died.
It could also potentially be Neil Prescott's
outfit from Scream One, which
looks the same.
But since Neil never died, I'm guessing he
got to keep his clothes.
I see no reason they would have ended up in
police custody.
This one was the hardest to place.
My first thought was that it was supposed
to be Casey Becker, because nobody
else died in a white long sleeve.
But it doesn't match, and she wasn't wearing
shorts.
My guess is that it's actually supposed to
be Jill's neighbor, Olivia Morris,
who was taken down while wearing a gray long
sleeve and flannel shorts.
It's not a perfect match, but it's my best
guess.
There's also a Woodsboro police uniform, meaning
that this belonged to
Deputy Hoss or Deputy Perkins, the two cops
who fell in the line of duty
while parked outside of Jill's house.
And we have a Stabathon t-shirt.
Stabathon was the movie marathon event hosted
by the Woodsboro High Film Club,
where Gale Weathers was nearly butchered.
In addition to those, there's also a case
full of Gale's books, most of
which we've seen before in Scream 3 and Four,
with one notable addition.
The Gale Weathers book that we haven't seen
before is Stabbed in the Back:
The Real Sunrise Story.
This actually comes from one of the promotional
websites for Scream 3,
Sunrise Sucks.
This was an anonymous expose site that published
dirt about the production
company responsible for the Stab franchise,
Sunrise Studios.
I talk about it extensively in my Horror History
episode on the history of
the Stab IP.
By the way, in Gale's apartment, there's one
new book called
The Woodsboro Horror Continues, which must
be the one she wrote about the
2022 or whenever it took place, Woodsboro
Massacre.
All of these theater shrine items were part
of Richie Kirsch's collection,
despite the fact that he claims that the first
Stab movie is the only good one.
He dies in Scream 2022, so it makes sense
that there wouldn't be much
from that movie.
However, I did notice the Stab Blu-ray box-set,
which was released at some
point between Screams Four and Five.
If there's one thing you can usually count
on in a requel, it's the new
characters taking up the mantle of the legacy
characters.
In the case of Scream, Sam Carpenter is the
new Sidney Prescott, and she
puts on the Ghostface costume to fight back
against Detective Bailey at the
end of the movie.
It's the very same Ghostface costume that
Sidney wore to strike back against
Billy Loomis approximately 27 years earlier.
And just like Billy, Bailey finds himself
on the wrong end of a Ghostface
call from his prey.
-[Sam] Hello, Detective Bailey.
-[Sam] Are you alone in the house?
Bailey is not the only one to suffer a very
1996 fate, Ethan pops up in the final reel
for one last scare and gets crushed by the
same TV that fell upon Stu Macher.
So what's the message this time? What are
the filmmakers trying to tell us?
Well, it's not that different from the last
movie.
This is kind of the second one in a row that
condemns toxic Internet
culture. This time, instead of toxic fandom,
it's about the phenomenon of
Reddit detectives who try to solve crimes
on their own and usually just end
up making things worse.
Wavywebsurf has a really good video on the
topic if you want to learn more.
Throughout the movie, Sam has to deal with
accusations that she was actually
the killer in Woodsboro, like this guy who
refers to her as being that
psycho girl.
He looks like he could be an actual Redditor.
Another chick recognizes her, dumps diet Cherry
Coke on her, and calls her a murderer.
Why would you dump a beverage on someone if
you believe she was a
murderer? That is not a smart move.
Even her psychiatrist starts to get creeped
out by her.
If you're like me, you probably wanted to
go back and look at the names in
the psychiatrist's filing cabinet to see if
there were any Easter eggs.
As far as I can tell, these are just random
patient names with no deeper meaning.
But Mars Jupiter is definitely a weird one.
Perhaps the biggest twist with this movie
is that none of the core
characters died.
It looked like Chad was a goner there for
a minute, but he miraculously
makes it out on a stretcher at the end.
Although during that part where Tara takes
off his oxygen mask to kiss him,
I wish he just would have died right there.
It would have been so ******* funny.
Click the playlist on the left for more of
my Scream franchise analysis videos,
and if you want to see everything you might
have missed in the
upcoming Scream 7, then make sure you subscribe
to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week.
Ring the deathbell for all notifications,
and I will see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.